donald trump has
filed a new lawsuit in georgia
challenging over 100 000 votes
essentially saying
shut her down we also have an update
that members of the pennsylvania
house and senate the republican party
are basically saying that the state was
not lawfully certified we also have
an order from supreme court justice
alito
well basically this lawsuit challenging
the constitutionality of mellon ballots
may be moving forward it was docketed
and these are major
issues that could change the election i
guess
right now the media has been adamantly
saying president-elect joe biden i was
watching a press conference from biden
earlier it was really funny
because all these journalists would
always say president-elect biden you
know blah blah blah ask a question
and then jobin actually brings up when i
won the election as all of you have now
noted and i'm like it's really weird
that they have to keep affirming it over
and over and over again and it could be
weird because trump keeps saying he
didn't lose i guess
but trump potentially has two states
being
tossed up right now i i'm not saying it
is probable
that he wins but these things are moving
forward and georgia is particularly
interesting
specifically because we got video that
came out just a couple days ago i think
maybe maybe even the other night that
shows some of the vote counters pulling
out boxes
so they say they pull that for their
surveillance footage actual video
evidence showing them
tell they walk up to people they say
something they don't know what they say
but according to sworn affidavits the
observers there
said that they were told to leave then
on the footage you see these people
pull boxes up from under tables and then
continue counting well according to the
sworn affidavits
they were the the observers were told
counting was stopping
it is also estimated that each box
contains about six thousand votes
and you know six times four you have
about 24 000 votes there
which coincides with a data released by
the new york times which was talked
about quite a bit
where just around 23 or so thousand
votes came in at 12 34
a.m around the exact same time all this
is happening i'm not saying it's
definitive proof of anything
i'm saying this is some of the hardest
evidence we've seen so far but georgia
has basically come out the republicans
saying
it's not true we've looked into this
there's nothing there's nothing
i don't find it satisfactory about it
very strange so we're going to talk
about this and a bunch of other things
the bay area is going on hard lockdown
california's ordering every
california is ordering everybody
basically stay in their homes and we're
about to see
what they're calling the strictest and
the harshest lockdowns we've seen yet
even amid governors like newsom
breaking their own rules rules for thee
but not for me so today
we're hanging out with luke caskey again
howdy i am the executive chairman and
head honcho of we are change.org
i like vanilla ice cream and interesting
fact about me
chris matthews of msnbc called me a
right-wing racist
tea bagger and bill o'reilly called me a
jihad loving liberal
so yeah that about describes you it's on
the news so it's true
and you're telling me just because joe
biden put president-elect in the
background of him
that doesn't make him the president
elect that's the creepiest thing
yeah i mean i thought that's how it
works no i mean i thought
i thought you know brian stelter over at
cnn could just say words and they were
true
like not that he reported the news but
that the words he said were infallible
and just
became reality it became true so that
when he went when he and all the other
anchors are like
joe biden is present elect there's a
literal ripple in space time
and we all get shocked back they're like
and then joe biden just
appears with the the words appear behind
him it's just
modern day wizards but uh they can't get
out of the shower correctly without
grabbing their dog's tail yes this is
the story that came out today according
to joe biden this is not the breaking
news he broke his foot
tipping over a shower when he was trying
to pull his okay okay
sorry i'm kidding this is supposed to be
just basic interruptions
we got a big breaking story trump is
suing georgia
again there's a dispute here this could
call the electoral votes
in a question but no okay we'll do the
breaking news joe biden said
he was getting out of the shower naked
chasing his dog and grabbing his tail
and slipped and broke his foot
and i love the memes they're like do we
have a president-elect or do we have a
four-year-old chasing the dog and
slipping
while naked like what what what is going
on with this did you guys hear
that uh joe biden said if he does he
basically said if he disagrees
with kamal harris like he said to obama
he would say he contracted a disease and
then resigned
and everyone's like what you said
yeah i started off with my video with
that today it's absolutely mind-boggling
to see this poor guy who has metal clips
in his head
literally holding back aneurysms i
didn't know this until you started
telling me about this
but but today's story of of what he says
happened is absolutely mind-boggling
because
he was playing with this dog naked out
of the shower but he's pulling his tail
yeah
he didn't mention why why would you pull
your dog's tail where does your foot
come in what are you doing
yes once like decided to grab the dogs
no idea but they have yet to explain it
and
i mean at least we can't say that the
next four years won't be interesting
uh they're going to be filled with a lot
of just
perplexing mind-boggling statements that
i'm absolutely looking forward to
because it shows you how untrustworthy
and absurd government is
i'd like in a joe biden presidency to
like a benny hill montage but i don't
think that joe biden is spry enough to
run through a bunch of different rooms
while being chased by a constable you
know what i mean
yeah he he has the hairline fracture he
can merely yeah but there's a picture of
him putting his full weight on it that
people are sending around
he's wearing the boot and then and then
he when he was doing the interview with
cnn they were like why aren't you
wearing the boot and he's like oh you
know it's a little clunky so
i'm not wearing it people think that uh
this is the conspiracy theory i guess i
don't know if it actually makes sense to
call it a conspiracy
they think that joe biden had to get a
ct scan
for his brain and so they just said all
right he broke his foot
and so then when he's telling his story
like how it happened it's one of the
most ridiculous stories you've ever
heard
guy getting out of the shower naked
chasing his dog around all slippery and
then falls and grabs his dog tail or
whatever and
freak why would he do that why why would
you grab your dog's tail
naked out of here hold on hold on hold
on hold on hold on i'm sorry i'm sorry
i should be framing this not in the like
actual neutral here's the report i
should be framing this in a politically
ideologically driven way like the media
does okay
joe biden uh ferociously abusing his dog
slips and falls shatters bone and ankle
oh my so angry see and then what you do
is the title should be
joe biden abusing his dog falls breaks
ankle
and then later on you say he was
grabbing his dog's tail comma which many
say
is animal abuse comma yes just add it
now now that we've established that we
can say
today in the news joe biden comma a
known animal abuser comma
was talking about his economic plan now
you can say he beats doug's
excellent congratulations this is the
cycle of media anyway this is a long
intro
ian's also hanging out he is a couple of
questions what's tea bagging
[Laughter]
family-friendly show uh i don't think
why did he call you that
well because of the tea party uh
connection chris matthews was saying any
anyone a part of the the tea party was a
tea bagger and that was this kind of
term against people uh yeah and he
mentioned it often write
that listed me and ron paul together as
sometimes okay hold on hold on i'd like
you to imagine
like what what kind of person do you
imagine when you think of the tea party
um poster after glenn beck took it over
i don't know just like it's 2012 right
wing i don't know like what
describe the person what do they look
like a tea party person are we talking
about like a little girl going to no
tea party or just the actual political
action yeah like
what's the first stereotypical view of a
tea party person
originally it was ron paul it was
libertarian it was right-wing and then
afterwards
and then people who are out waving the
flags yes those were kind of glenn beck
sarah palin enthusiasts but what do they
look like
average americans they were they were
like slightly older
not old middle-aged white dudes yeah
the men so i want you to imagine what
chris matthews is thinking
when he's imagining a bunch of these
like middle-aged white dudes waving
flags all bobbing up and down
like i'm not going to explain what tea
bagging is yes you don't want to do that
but i actually talked to chris matthews
one-on-one about this i went up to him
during one of the presidential debates
and i was like hey i'm luke from
we are change wrc he's like wait i know
that from somewhere
like you do yes and that's because you
slandered and lied about me and my news
organization
and he's like no i didn't i'm like yes
you did i'm like
i'm like we got an argument he was like
i never said that i never did it
i don't know what you're talking about
you're crazy i literally pulled out my
phone i was like you wait right here you
stay right here don't move anywhere
pulled up my phone played the video for
him i was like you watch this like
and he looked he looked at the video and
he looked at the microphone that said we
are changed he's like
oh right i gotta go
i don't know i thought you were with
somebody else i gotta get out of here
i'm like you have
no honor you have no i i was like what
is the evidence
what information did you have to slander
and label me this
what did you do like how like because
that's a major declaration
you have to understand at those times
especially when barack obama was
president
the spoc listed me ron paul and many
other libertarians right along
the kkk they even made introverts what
do you think they do today
yeah i mean it's that's what it kind of
began with
and i remember facing him one on one i
was like answer me tell me why you uh
slandered me didn't have an answer see
all the stuff
all the stuff we're seeing now with like
how the media smears and slanders people
on the right
and cancel culture you were you were
like right there in the front you were
the first to be you know well not the
first to be but in the culture
war they started maligning you and ron
paul and all that but then they actually
you were the you were the first
to be demonetized the first selectively
monetized with different
videos specifically not knowing what was
going on
we talked to many different executives
we even snuck into some parties where
i was able to talk to the head of uh
youtube monetization and
this is before there was any kind of
concept of monetization yeah or like
demonetization well yeah yeah no one
even knew what was going on
and then we you know you used to have a
green a dollar sign but then
some of our videos didn't have anything
and no one knew what was going on at all
and three-fourths of our income was
taken away now it's
of course there was no yellow dollar
sign yeah there was no yellow before
yellow there was just blank
and no explanation and no even
guidelines or community strikes nothing
uh so you you went through the terms of
services that said nothing about this
exact scenario or situation
so we were kind of left scratching our
heads like what what's going on
here let's talk to some of these people
we reached out to a lot of them talked
to them one-on-one including the head
of youtube monetization at that youtube
party that me and you stuck snuck into
with casey neistat
and behind him when he was running in
there that was great and
you know behind a famous person you get
in any building exactly i mean we could
get into all these little
all right all right well that's a hold
on we'll come back we gotta start talk
about breaking news don't forget lydia
has also been sitting here i am
another corner i push all the buttons
now that we've made it through the
introduction make sure you smash the
like button subscribe notification bell
all that good stuff
check us out on itunes spotify and all
that if you want to catch the show if
you missed the live show but let's talk
about this breaking news man this is
huge
the election is not over from al jazeera
trump campaign challenges over 100 000
votes in georgia
new lawsuit is latest in long line of
trump challenges
to u.s election results most of which
have been thrown out
president trump's campaign filed another
lawsuit seeking over to overturn
the united states election results the
campaign announced friday this time
contesting more than 100 000 votes in
the state of georgia
the new lawsuit filed by the trump
campaign and georgia's republican party
alleges that massive irregularities
mistakes and potential fraud took place
in the state
now you know what i really really love
about this latest lawsuit
when the republican party is in it with
trump and they're saying yes
look at all these problems and then when
giuliani drops an actual video and
there's a lawyer an attorney
saying look at this video of people
pulling ballot boxes out from under a
table
after they told everyone to leave and
then counting tens of thousands of votes
at into one into one am with no
observers present
george's gop secretary of state says he
has already
investigated bombshell video rudy
giuliani claims proof voting fraud
and says it shows nothing out of the
ordinary you mean to tell me
that once everyone leaves they
immediately scuttle over and pull box
out from other tables and then start
counting them
up until 1am and that's normal i want to
know what's ordinary
yeah in the first place but giuliani is
calling this the smoking gun and the
bank heist video
i mean you could make a lot of
interpretations but i hope the person in
the video is
set to testify i hope she's under oath
and i hope we find out what happened
with that usb
that was clutched and so so that's not
true that's not in the story but people
have been posting a video
that shows a woman with blonde braids
they say it's the same person
i'll be very careful because i don't
know what this video is but you see this
woman
she's sitting talking to someone and
then she palms a usb stick
and then clutches it and the camera's
like zoomed in and she stands up and
then like slides it in her pocket
there are other videos of people doing
this there's a
for what reason are they putting usb
sticks into
like voting terminals at these polling
locations and then pocketing them and
walking out
because you'd think if it was something
routine they'd walk right up and pull
the stick and put it in there and talk
to people and then
take it out look at it and you know put
it away but they're like palming it like
trying to hide it so i don't know who
that lady is in that video
i can only assume they're saying it's
the same person but that is crazy
it's crazy to me is that's the kind of
evidence that you get
bill barr saying there's no evidence
we've seen to date that
you know would have changed outcome of
the election yeah watching someone stick
a usb stick in a machine
and then pull it out isn't proof that
the election was
you know flipped but it is evidence that
somebody broke the law
you just can't say they changed the
results of the election he also said so
far
so we're still yeah yeah today so we're
still waiting for the exact
information it's important not to jump
to conclusions but with these
important events it's important to pay
attention to them
and hope that it goes through the right
legal process where people could
actually get the right information and
find out more
under oath exactly what happened here
because i mean a lot of people
in the mainstream media are saying
enough let's stop asking questions it's
already done we have the president-elect
but
if we could have four years of absolute
russian collusion
madness i think we could allow a few
weeks to ask some serious questions
about our elections which by the way
all the mainstream media pundits telling
you to trust the election results
we're just telling you not to trust it
months ago especially john oliver on his
hbo show who
actually did a pretty good job about
dominion voting machines
and the entire problem with electronic
voting machines
last year and uh now he's denying it now
if you're questioning the elections
you're part of i think he said
uh a fascistic government or you're
you're crazy if you're questioning this
this year's elections i don't know his
exact quote so i don't want to miscode
him
but he's on the complete other spectrum
where he was
a year ago providing pretty good solid
evidence pretty good
questions pretty good uh you know
evidence laid out in front of us
saying that there are some legitimate
questions that should be asked about the
integrity of our elections i watched
this video
that they put out where you can see them
pulling out a box from under a table
there's a website called lead stories
which has uh defamed me and published
fake news about me uh
they so i had a tweet about epstein and
about bill clinton being in flight logs
and you know witness iding him and they
took that tweet called it fake news
but then wrote their their fact check
which basically confirmed everything
it's just like
it's it's a scam they say here's the
article here's the truth and they don't
care what you actually said
they just want to make sure that on
facebook people who see it it says fake
news
so they fact checked this story about
giuliani
and they say it's fake news it was legal
ballot counting
nothing to see here why well they asked
someone
and that someone said don't worry
everything's fine that explains it
case closed but here's the best part one
of the quotes they have
this is this is what the person says
they say francis watson chief
investigator for the georgia secretary
of state
yes the gop who said that we've already
looked into it nothing to see here
told lead stories during a phone call on
december 3rd that the ballots were in
standard containers
no one's disputing that and the work
during the time in question had nothing
to do with pulling ballots from
under the table she said quote there
wasn't a bin that had balance in it
onto the table so what did we see them
pull out from under the table that was a
ballot box full of ballots and then
start counting it wasn't empty
she says it was an empty bin and the
ballots from it were actually out on the
table when the media were still there
and then it was placed back into the box
when the media were still there and
placed
next to the table there is a video you
can watch
where a woman with braids walks up to a
group of people then those people all
leave
then they walk over to the table pull a
box out from under the table
four boxes they do it multiple times and
this person who's debunking this says it
was placed
next to the table you can literally
watch the video where it's not next to
the table
this is not a real fact check did
giuliani actually say it was proof
oh yeah the headline said that he said
it was proof he's saying it's the
smoking gun
he didn't say evidence he said proof he
tweeted election in georgia is now
proven to be a fraud
then he tweeted again the videotape
doesn't lie fulton county democrats
stole the election it's now beyond doubt
go to the tape
smoking gun from georgia he's destroying
his credibility by
throwing the word proof around so ha
haphazardly because that's
might be evidence but it's definitely
not proof something it's the hardest
evidence we have so far
but there's so there was a a document
that was going around
showing the the vote tabulations in real
time there's been a whole bunch of
analysis around this now in one of these
uh data dumps it was at
i think like 12 34 a.m and this is from
the new york times
the new york times like data release on
the election night so it's december
i'm sorry november 4th 12 34 a.m around
23
900 or so ballots came in and 98 were
for joe biden
now people are seeing this video and
going back to those
uh articles and those you know analyses
saying wait a minute
on this day in georgia at 12 34 a.m we
know they stopped counting
at 1 a.m that means you've got
four ballot boxes you can see in the
video each estimated contains six
thousand votes
twenty four thousand votes now people
are going back to the previous data and
saying
ninety eight percent for joe biden that
looks like
it's that they're tabulating those
ballot boxes they pull from under the
table so is it
is it proof is it the smoking gun i
think
if you went to a regular person and show
them that video they'd be like what
if you then show them the data from the
from the from the you know the the
election counting releases that were
coming in
people your average person is probably
going to be like oh yeah
so i'm not saying it's i'm not saying
it's true i'm just saying when it comes
to these situations that are extremely
political
it's proving something beyond a
reasonable doubt for me i look at this
and i'm like how do you argue against it
what do you have to say when they're
like oh no no it's next to the table no
it wasn't
it was it was normal ballot counting
then why do we have two sworn affidavits
from people saying they were told they
had to leave and counting it stopped
not only that in georgia you know they
claimed a water main broke
and they had to stop counting never
happened what an election i remember
this they were like a water main broke
in georgia so they're sending everybody
home
really weird we also had a story where a
guy apparently was a leaky toilet that's
it
like what does that have to do why can't
you count votes because of a leaky
toilet
there's another story where a guy said
that in georgia they told everyone they
had to leave
because counting was done they're like
no we're not leaving so they drove a
forklift and blocked the view so they
couldn't actually see what's going on
yeah it doesn't help your cause when
you're trying to block people from
seeing what you're doing and it doesn't
help your cause when you have a record
of steel stealing elections just like
the dnc did against bernie sanders
so uh i still no matter what have to
give the benefit of the doubt until we
have their side of the ver
their side of the story their version of
events i'm still waiting
until these court proceedings happen i i
i want to see more i want to see
everything and i want to hear the
counter-argument to what we're seeing
right now because i think we
definitely deserve there's no real
argument right now well they're just
look look that's why i pulled up the
fact check yeah when they publish a
quote where it's like they looked into
it and it said it was nothing i'm like
that's that's look i get it that's not a
response i want that lady under oath
explaining her exactly what she was
doing every little thing
uh you know described in detail because
we deserve that exactly coming out and
saying
trust me yeah no i watched their liars
they're like
yeah they cheated bernie sanders out of
the no these are the republicans these
are the georgia republicans it's it's
it's it's raffensburger and it's brian
county
i'm talking about an enlarger picture in
this whole election
what we're seeing happening here there's
definitely a lot of anomalies that don't
make sense
for sure and i think it was wrong what
happened to bernie especially in 2016
and now but
i do have to say if you won't fight for
yourself why do you expect me to fight
for you he took it he bent over and he
was like yes support hillary
after everyone knew including his own
supporters who who were just
shocked bernie bernie bernie sanders in
2016 the millionaires and the
billionaires
in this country are exploding the
working class and then in 2020
in 2020 no no outside of that 2020 he
goes the million
not the millionaires the billionaires in
this country are supporting joe biden
vote for him
when you say he got cheated out of the
election i know i've heard some stuff
about
what what the dnc did when you look at
debbie wasserman schultz and the way
that she was getting the electors during
the selection
you saw the rise in numbers you saw the
there's a lot of
different little tricks that were used
uh
you know during the primaries that a lot
of people directly point the finger
at the dnc head debbie wasserman schultz
which
was uh she she was fired she she
essentially was
ousted as the dnc chair and hired
immediately afterwards for the hillary
clinton campaign
uh and then and again this is also the
same person that looked at me and told
me that there wasn't a deposition matrix
this position
disposition matrix i keep messing it up
uh but but
again when you look at the they were
feeding questions to the media so that
hillary had advantages and debates
there are leaked emails where they were
basically talking about how they were
doing everything in their power to help
hillary clinton and something about his
jewishness right in the leaked emails i
don't know about i don't remember
any of that but we do we do have uh uh
some more serious information
uh uh news pertaining to georgia so this
is from just last night president
trump's attorneys asked
georgia legislature to overturn election
select
own electors and they might do it how do
you think this is gonna play out this is
what i really wanted to kind of you know
how and where do we go from here well
there's
so so there's some things that could
happen for one
we get pennsylvania michigan and georgia
if these three states maybe arizona
maybe nevada
if their legislatures which are which
are controlled by republicans
dispute the election and won't shut up
about it
then by december we're four days out
if they don't rectify this in four days
that's it yeah i don't see those votes
those votes aren't gonna count
trump's gonna win i'm not saying he's
probably probably gonna win i'm not
saying he's likely to
but i'm saying if the legislatures
dispute this
it doesn't matter what the governor say
because the constitution is clear that
the legislatures decide
if the if the state legislatures issue a
statement to
the the supreme court or the federal
government saying here's what we think
or just send their own slate of electors
without even coming into session
then you're going to have you know
pennsylvania has 40 electors
instead of instead of 20 and then what
which ones do we count i don't know
democrats are going to be we got to
count to one the joe biden one no we
dispute you gotta count the trump ones
yeah hypothetically if donald trump wins
i could really see people imploding
floating i could see people exploding uh
in the amount of frustration
their heads will explode and then their
quivering masses will start to
slowly come together like the terminator
and terminator 2 and i
will turn into a giant rage monster if
it happens i will be watching cnn
intently and i never thought i would say
that
but how do you see the rest of america
responding to this because a lot of
people are pointing to
potentially even a bigger conflict look
what they did look what they did in uh
january 20th 2016.
2017 sorry 2017. yeah they went around
yeah yeah we were we were both there and
they went around burning
they they torched at immigrants you know
that poor that poor working-class
immigrants limo
he would he had his own limo as a
contractor he would give people rides
they torched it that was a very
famous site as well as the garbage can
that was on fire with the rest of the
mainstream media around it but it's
because they're like limousines are for
the rich and it's like
it's some poor guy who leased it to run
a business to drive people around he's
not rich they don't care
so if look man i'll tell you this if
trump does find a way
to flip this i'm boarding up my windows
man and i'm in the middle of nowhere
okay i'm not really going to board up my
windows but i don't think you need to
uh not out here but uh we we we went to
the we went to the armory the other day
yeah
of course luke and uh yeah we went there
and uh uh
that was really fun bottom out yes it's
very important to be able to defend
yourself and have the right to defend
yourself
a lot of politicians have a lot of
security guards with machine guns and
guns around them
and they think that they could afford
themselves protection but you
shouldn't have any protection at all
which is absolutely ridiculous and i
think
one of the core strengths of the united
states that makes it as
special as it is right now is the
ability of individuals
to be able to arm themselves the second
amendment is extremely important
and i think we're heading down a very
dangerous road
rather whether donald trump wins or
whether
biden comes in and then tries to
restrict that right take away the right
of individuals to defend themselves
i think it's going to be a very big
clash point between americans saying no
this is absolutely not okay we had on
destiny the other night and i think
one of the arguments he brought up is
the perfect example of why
joe biden thinks he's completely
justified in stripping away your rights
when uh destiny he's a leftist
mentioned that we need a two-month hard
lockdown and the government should
support people i said
don't people have rights his response
and this is something i've heard a lot
from the left is
do you what do you have a right to drive
your car drunk
and my response is you don't need to
drive your car drunk
you do need to make a living and work a
job and run your business and pay your
employees like
those are things you need to do yeah
yeah so so that's completely different
yeah the argument is totally irrelevant
but think about how democrats
that's how they think they're like you
can't drive your car drunk why would you
go outside and get someone else sick and
it's like
because we have to win but you need to
eat but you can't steal food if you
can't afford it
you don't have the right to steal food
if you don't have enough money for it
but what does that have to do
if you need to eat but you don't you
don't have a right to steal but we give
people food we have food banks we have
we have welfare cards not sometimes we
literally no
no everyone has access to that stuff
well
they're just saying it's a technicality
but like you can go to food banks you
can get ebt cards
i think i think every state has has an
electronic benefits
system so if you steal food
when you can go to the department of
human services and
you know we have welfare programs it's
very different from getting drunk and
driving your car
not only that you know what the penalty
is for stealing food
typically slap on the wrist yeah you
know the penalty is for driving drunk
yeah driving is dangerous yeah it's a
felony you can't drive anymore you go to
jail you get an ankle bracelet it
depends on the state of course some
states are more severe than others for
sure but there's
there's more here we got just just oh
you know before we go on i got evidence
about this dnc
telling trying to trash bernie for being
jewish
yeah it's an email this is from politico
uh from the dnc cfo brad marshall
sending it out to a bunch of
dnc uh people and it said uh it may
don't read it don't read it verbatim if
they're trash no it's nothing nothing
that you can't say online but it's cruel
that they would do this it may um
it might may no difference it's a typo
but for
kentucky and west virginia can we get
someone to ask his belief does he
believe in a god he had skated on saying
is a jewish heritage
i think i read he's an atheist this
could make several points difference
with my peeps my southern baptist peeps
will draw a big difference between a jew
and an atheist
marshall wrote in a message to several
dnc communication directors so we
we we have uh there's a lot to talk
about right so there's a reason why i
highlight
uh georgia and trump's attorneys asking
georgia's legislature to overturn the
election and select their own electors
because we have we have this going on
right now
supreme court again is asked to block
biden in pennsylvania
justice alito has given let me read it
they say
in a sign that the case okay let me stop
this is act 77
it is the no excuse mail in voting the
absentee expansion in pennsylvania
several republicans and uh brought uh
brought the suit to
uh the courts the lead plaintiff mike
kelly
won his election if they overturn or the
judge's rule this election was
unconstitutional
he causes damage to his own career that
was noted by the judge
they're saying that uh no excuse mail in
voting is a violation of the
constitution
it was thrown out by the pennsylvania
supreme court on narrow grounds that
sorry you took too long to file but in
the uh lower court's ruling they said
that that these republicans will likely
win on the merits
and what does that mean i don't know it
could nullify pennsylvania outright
well they've filed to the supreme court
and alito they say
in a sign that the case is likely too
late to affect the election justice
samuel alito ordered the state's lawyers
to respond by december 9th
a day after what is known as the safe
harbor deadline
that means that congress cannot
challenge any electors named by
named by this date in accordance with
state law
state law is irrelevant to the
constitutional process
the the constitution says the
legislature decides how the elections
are run
and who the electors are internally the
supreme court can complain about the
legislature but what the legislature
says to the federal government in terms
of their electors is an entirely
different matter
more importantly it's really interesting
because i'm seeing
two messages from the left they're
saying if
alito supreme court justice has ordered
the the the state
to answer by the ninth that's after the
safe harbor provision meaning
they didn't uh bring the dispute in soon
enough therefore
the electors are certified case closed
biden wins
but that makes literally no sense i
actually have from congress.gov
it says december 8 2020 the safe harbor
deadline the u.s code provides that if
election results are contested in any
state
and if the state prior to election day
has enacted procedures to settle
controversies or contests over the
electors
and electoral votes and if these
procedures have been
applied and the results have been
determined six days before the elector's
meetings
then these results are considered to be
conclusive and will apply in the
counting of the electoral votes
okay based on my reading of that let me
let's ask let's ask a few questions they
say
if results are contested in any state
all right question are there results
contested in any state by
official governing bodies yeah
yes it seems like it of course yes i'm
just a newbie
is it contested yes yeah in michigan
in nevada in arizona in georgia in
pennsylvania there are active disputes
all right
and it's prior to uh uh prior to
election day
interest and if the state prior to
election day has enacted procedures to
settle controversies or contests over
electors and electoral votes
have they does that mean general court
system
does that resolve the new complaints
that have come up relative to fraud that
happened
after the fact see this is where things
get confusing
they say if these procedures have been
applied has anything been applied to
rectify
complaints about voter fraud from the
legislature especially in pennsylvania
who have called for an emergency session
perhaps they would perhaps the argument
is because i'm not a lawyer
the governor has to call a special
session because he didn't there you go
there's there's there's you know no
resolution but now my question is this
what if the supreme court is saying we
want your answer by the ninth
some conservatives are saying alito set
a trap that
if they they now have to wait till the
ninth to issue their
you know response maybe they can do it
sooner if they do
then there is a dispute active the
supreme court requested a response
then wouldn't veteran just basically
avoid those electoral
electoral college votes that's that's
the question here who knows i mean trump
really wants this to go to the supreme
court because he knows he has the
advantage there
and he has a lot of prior lawyers that
were on the bush team
in the 2000 contested elections as well
we
i mean that was contested all the way
until mid-december so how is this going
to unfold especially if the votes aren't
certified if this goes to the supreme
court who's going to rule what
it's 2020. i think anything could happen
at this point i think but it's very hard
to predict
i think it's the fact that the supreme
court is involved which makes this
questionable because
the way there's two ways people are
reading it and um
some people are saying if they're not
resolving this dispute and applying no
nothing to resolve the controversies
because they still exist then
they haven't met the deadline and the
elections in dispute but it says
my understanding is okay there's a
controversy
if the state has a way to resolve these
before election day which many of the
states do you go to court you file
lawsuits
and if they've enacted procedures to do
such many of these things have gone to
court
and they've been thrown out or whatever
then it sounds like it's all resolved
but the supreme court steps in and says
this is actually escalating
and if they have to wait till the ninth
and the supreme court hasn't chosen to
accept or dismiss
there's an act of controversy in
pennsylvania how could they then meet
that deadline
in fact it sounds like this actually is
bad news for democrats
because there's no way they can resolve
it if it's going to supreme court
unless of course they sue and argue we
it's irrelevant what the supreme court
says to us because the state has already
finished this
you know i'll put it this way there
there are legal experts who have said
it's not going to happen it's certified
it's done there's nothing they can do
about it the supreme court has
has no say right the way i put it is
you have to understand that these are
human beings who can choose to rule and
and exercise that power like when the
other day when we were talking about
uh the ballot observation in
pennsylvania a judge
actually ruled when when trump's
campaign giuliani they were like
682 000 votes were counted with no
observer
and the judge is like were there are
observers in the room and trump's
lawyers are like
well yes but they didn't have meaningful
access they couldn't look at the ballots
the judge said
well the election code doesn't say how
close you have to be
therefore or they're paid off or
or he's crooked so when you and then and
then the left cheers for it okay i'll
tell you what
if you're going to cheer for what is
obvious to any sane person a ridiculous
ruling
we know what observers are for there's
that you know you see that photo from
florida where they're like staring at
the ballots with the pen and pointing at
it
they're there to observe what the heck
and and make sure that people
are counting properly for a judge to be
like well they were in the room
the election code doesn't specify
distance so
other ones were kicked out and not
allowed even in right so
you know but as long as there's one as
long as there's one that is not
what the intent of the law was so i tell
you if they can do that if they can rule
that way and the left cheers for it
then i'll tell you this if if the
supreme court takes this up
and then the the the four liberal
justices i include robertson that
versus the five and the five say we
don't care we're the supreme court
here's our opinion boom it's done
it's that's it and they can say so
there's there's there's
we got huge news look at this we got a
letter check this out it's a huge letter
i think what this is this was posted to
uh well this being shared around quite a
bit
they say 76 members of the pennsylvania
general assembly
they're basically saying three usc 15
empowers congress to reject electoral
votes
that are not regularly given or lawfully
certified
the aforementioned conduct has
undermined the lawful certification of
pennsylvania's delegation to the
electoral college for these reasons we
the undersigned members of the
pennsylvania general assembly
urge you to object and vote to sustain
such objection
to the electoral college votes received
from the commonwealth of pennsylvania
during the joint session of congress on
january 6 2021
we have pennsylvania state legislator
officially now
requesting from p.a house gop news
i'm i'm assuming this is legit we've got
all these people who have signed on to
this
if they have submitted this saying
straight up the results are disputed
we object how is pennsylvania going to
be counted properly and sick on january
6.
you're going to have republican members
of congress who represent districts in
pennsylvania saying
we have submitted this letter we reject
these votes deal with it is that enough
to get trump to win
no that puts biden at 286. they need
two more states well even if so check it
out if they get pennsylvania
and michigan then biden's at 270. he
wins they get pennsylvania and georgia
biden's at 270 he wins
they need three states in order to make
this happen
it's actually not that hard to do which
is kind of crazy
it's possible but it's still a very big
uphill battle and there's a lot of
uncertainties and a lot there's a lot of
things
that haven't ever happened before when
we saw what happened in 2000 it was
between
bush and gore in one state and
one state right and a bunch of different
counties doing different things yes
and you know that was still extremely
complicated
this what all the other states
complicates it tenfold
and and now we're set into no man's land
where we never were before
there's still a lot of contention
there's even donald trump saying that he
might not go to the inauguration he
might win his own event one day he's
saying he'll concede another day he's
saying that
he said quote if we are right about the
fraud joe biden can't be the president
that's that's an exact you know quote
there so there's a lot in the air here
what are you
and uh so so listen listen i've heard a
lot from the media that trump would stay
jakku and all this stuff but the media's
hysterical
trump arrangement syndrome so i'll ask
you what do you think the chances are
that it's january 19th or whatever and
trump gives an uh
an address where he's like evidence of
chinese influence and interference
joe biden we've seen the math we've seen
the evidence he shows the videos he
shows the charts and then says
i refuse to you know to accept this
and trump's already got loyalists in in
key positions especially in the pentagon
what do you think the chances are well
he has some loyalists but
if you look at the trump presidency it
is mirrored
in individuals leaking information oh
yeah
and backstabbing him and crossing him
and you know vice versa there's a lot of
foul play within the establishment
against donald trump
that's definitely fair so donald trump
doesn't have the establishment he
doesn't have a lot of the hardcore
washington d.c insiders he doesn't have
the media he doesn't have social media
he has a couple guys with trucks that
that ride around
with his uh flag on there but uh it's
it's
an extremely big uphill battle you know
he should have known better
because when he came in he took the
advice of a lot of these crony
rhinos yeah and so they were like yeah
yeah you know
you want sessions for you know for aging
you want you want uh
uh bolton he brought out henry kissinger
he sat down with henry kissinger before
he got elected
he he congratulated him he was like it
was like he was going to play ball with
him a little bit
exactly and then and there was and then
it was nice out and they were all
grinning and trump thought that he could
come in and say okay i'll work with you
guys we're going to do things my way
like yeah whatever you say trump and
then they unsheath those blades
and then a couple we took trump a couple
of years to finally be like
i really should have just fired everyone
yeah as i know it's you know it's funny
you know it's funny
people say that he won't pardon snowden
or assange because he's called them both
you know treasonous traitors spies and
all stuff
but but there was a funny tweet where
someone uh i think glenn greenwald
tweeted about it
and then someone said why would trump
pardon them he's repeatedly insulted
them and called them you know names
and then glenn greenwald said something
the effect of maybe it's because
he these people are have targeted the
deep state
intelligence agencies which attacked and
and you know harassed trump for years
and now he will enjoy some comeuppance
or some karma for these people yeah i
mean he has the power to do it but we
also have to
understand that it's because of the
trump administration why julian assange
is where he is
right now it's because of his direct
actions and his administration
that assange is in such a terrible place
but you know snowden just tweeted out
don't pardon me please pardon assange
save his
life his life is on the line you know
why trump is doing it
and why trump did what obama wouldn't
why i think
trump wants to know who wikileaks
sources are
that was that was the part of the deal
part of the bargain that allegedly
happened between the trump
administration and assange that was
public
uh that assange yeah i mean wasn't that
public i don't know that
i remember reading articles about that
in hearing about that specific story
that trump wanted to know who the source
was for the dnc leaks
and if assange gave it to him assange
would be let go if he didn't
he would feel the full brunt of the u.s
empire and he did and
julian assange will not sacrifice his
legacy and his his organization
and so you got to give him up to you got
to give it up to him i mean that's
courageous
he's sitting in solitary confinement
gave up his life because he wouldn't
give up his source
and that's more integrity than an iota
of what the mainstream yeah they'll make
a movie they'll make like movies but you
know what you know what the
you know the scary thing about it is the
difficult question if we
did get the source for the dnc leaks
officially on record from assange i
think
it would have been a game changer that
would have reshaped the culture war and
politics in this country especially
between a russia gate
and where we are today with ukraine gate
everything happened the impeachment
it would have i i believe
are you referring to seth rich no okay
so that
that's that's i don't i don't know what
where that all is but i do know
that you had someone from wikileaks say
that they were handed the drive
right if maybe it was russia maybe it
wasn't the point is it would have either
confirmed
or didn't or or rejected that conclusion
in which case we would have known
definitively
let's say it was russia if we got that
answer out of
assange then we could have been like
whoa trump did get information
wikileaks was used as a as an useful
idiot so that they could
undermine blah blah blah or it turns out
the media and everything was wrong
and it undermines that entire russia
gate but at the same time he's still
accommodating to the lunatics in the
mainstream media that are literally
regurgitating and making crazy theories
up
about russian uh why would you even try
to appease him and if you try to appease
him in exchange for julian assange's
life i mean that's
messed up that's absolutely horrible and
and i agree this is a complex picture
you can't just
paint donald trump black or white good
or bad it's
far more complex than that because he
did talk about bringing the troops back
he actually brought back 700 u.s
troops from somalia no no they're
getting they're getting moved around
well they're getting whatever out out of
there he's trying and most of americans
didn't even know that the united states
had troops positions
increasing west wars dude yeah there's
an africom
whole entire u.s military unit inside
of the whole african continent raging
war
right now you know arming different
factions and
i've been there i've been on the front
lines in somalia and the picture that's
happening there
is not a good one and it doesn't do any
favors to the united states so
i i mean when it comes to assange i mean
look at the work he did look at the
information he
he released especially with bradley
manning chelsea man excuse me
uh especially with everything we were we
actually got to find out about the
u.s military-industrial complex that we
would never know if it was
as as many on the right say the reason
why they're adamant about trump
pardoning assange and snowden is that
they exposed the deep state
yes these intelligence man think about
how crazy it is
that for the longest time if you came
out and said
they're they're waging a secret war in
somalia they beg ooh he's crazy guy
thinks the cia is coming to get him they
call you a conspiracy theorist crackpot
and then trump comes along and all of a
sudden not just trump but with assange
people like snowden
the veil starts to get removed and it
turns out could you imagine if the
american people actually knew
how many secret wars we were engaged in
what they would do
they'd probably revolt yeah people don't
realize this mo's and
and and you know what makes it makes it
work the mainstream media these large
media organizations are complicit
they cover it up because i'll tell you
this
i was in a i was at a resort in turkey
in um what's uh what's the eastern city
in turkey where they do this this is
it's like the russian resort i can't
remember the name
tons of rich people i was brought there
by this by the executives at vice
top level people top men top men top men
they bring me to this resort antalya i
think that's what it's called
so i'm hanging out with with the the
global elites man i'm talking we're
talking people who run telecoms
like ceos etc they're having this
meeting where they're talking about
north korea
because vice had gone into north korea
multiple times
and so you get all these rich people
sitting around and and you get shane
smith
who mentions that the state department
actually contacted
vice following the uh the north korea
documentary stuff they did
i actually worked on one of the north
korea documentaries for vice called
north korean
motorcycle diaries i went to new zealand
for that because they had the footage it
was the crew that the people they run
motorcycles through north korea
the state department wanted to talk to
vice about it so when you actually have
people in the u.s government and i'm not
saying it's a conspiracy it's not they
go there and say this is what you report
or else
it's look look look we've got serious
security concerns
we just want to make sure that what your
report doesn't get anybody killed you
don't want
us to come out and say you got someone
killed you know no no no no so we're
going to tell you
okay just to be sure and then you'll get
like the new york times the wall street
journal the washington post i don't care
what what their leaning is
they're going to have a story and it's
going to be like we uncovered something
and then they're going to get a phone
call saying that will undermine national
security or they're going to
national security leverage story's gone
then assange
drops it right on the internet and we
can all watch it
well the system that you're describing
gets overused and abused
many times as even regular stories that
don't have any implications don't put
anyone's life on the line
are actually censored because they make
the united states look bad that has
happened a lot and we have found out
because of chelsea manning's
uh drop that that one of the major
allegations that the mainstream media
was
was labeling against her was that she
put american soldiers at lives
at the court perspective at risk yeah
yeah that
people were going to die because of
these leaks i was
at the court proceedings where chelsea
manning was
at at uh what was it uh what's the
specific military court called
leavenworth oh i don't know um there was
a specific military procedure
where she was being tried i was there
and it came out that there was
no one put at risk because of these
leaks that were
that were put out there but she still
was oddly punished by the obama
administration and then pardoned by the
obama administration
now donald trump hates her look at his
way
you've got a plan and then some dude
comes out and tells everyone what your
plan is you're going to be really really
angry and annoyed and that's and that's
it and
the issue with the with assange manning
with snowden michael flynn
with isis yeah is that if if
if we need to make an example of you
michael flynn's a really good example
because i didn't i didn't i didn't
realize that
until you brought it up that michael
flynn basically what did he he snitched
exposed how barack obama was responsible
for the rise of isis in the middle east
knowingly he knew there was leaked
documents that came out
that showed exactly what was going to
happen it did
radical fundamentalists were going to
receive the money the arms the
intelligence the hardware
the trucks that were sent down there
this is why isis was
riding around with jim bob's
construction trucks from the united
states
and everyone was like wait why did they
have there's a phone number phone number
on it from michigan yes
they were running around with humvees us
military humvees that they knew
they were going to get in iraq and
there's even leaked documents coming out
how
the u.s military command knew that they
were going to get control of all this
from the u.s military and they let it
and this is why they thought or they
they claimed that flynn was compromised
by russia because syria was allies with
russia
and all the pieces come together exactly
but he came out and read it on them
and that they got to make an example
because they don't want anybody else to
do it
so listen you could you could
commit a major felony right and they'll
and they'll say
okay yeah sure we're gonna we're gonna
lock you up and go the system but you
slight the machine and they are going to
gut and they're gonna eviscerate you and
leave you hanging to dry
as the public watches because now you
know we're hearing a judge just
said in the part in in the in the pardon
of michael flynn
that perhaps sullivan could order that
the pardon is too broad
and try to nullify it how psychotic
is this that is a supreme power granted
to the president
okay a lot of people have complaints
about the pardon power
it exists for a reason i actually read a
great essay on i can't remember exactly
what the breakdown was
but they say there's a very serious and
important reason why the president has
the ability to just
pardon people when it comes to federal
crimes but if the president does
so be it that's at least the rules for
now if you don't like the rules you
change the rules later with legislation
the fact that they're saying
that sullivan who was blocking the fact
that doj was trying to let flynn go
like doj says we're going to drop this
we don't want to do it anymore and then
you get this judge saying no
no you can't do that then trump says i
unequivocally pardoned
now there's one judge going i don't know
that's a little broad sullivan could say
no to that
oh we can't say do we not the president
the president so
it will i don't think anything's come of
it but man are these people
nuts so i'll tell you this the reason
why it is absolutely
important in my opinion that
we get resolution on all of what's going
on the election irregularity
is because we are we you know i often
say we're sitting on a powder keg
the fuse is coming and we're staring at
it that powder powder keg's about to go
january 6 is around the corner january
20th around the corner and you got 74
million people saying
what is going on with this election i
don't trust it more than that probably
you got 30
of democrats according to a couple
different polls that think votes were
stolen
so you've got people charged up and
ready and angry
people are going to snap as we were
locked down
denied sports and are now being put
back into lockdown having all of our
livelihoods destroyed in front of us i
mean this is an absolute
recipe for disaster so many people are
discontent so many people are angry a
lot of them are just
breaking stuff because they have nothing
else to do if you go to major democratic
cities
you could protest you could riot yep you
could work nope you could go check that
you can't go to church you can't have
sporting events you can't have you can't
go to the clubs you can't go to the
restaurants you can't do anything except
riot it's simple when uh when ryan long
was here he's a comedian
super funny guy he's ryan long comedy
it's really really great stuff you
probably love it
he was saying that you know he's in new
york they couldn't go outside or do
anything the black lives matter protest
started and he was like
i want to go outside and that was it
they got those massive numbers
you see that video in california of all
the people in the street as a drone
flies over
it's because people were desperate let
me out into the sun please
any excuse i'll say anything and it
worked yep
i will say anything and a lot of people
are angry at the police for enforcing
a lot of these decrees i call it
breakers yeah yeah a lot of people were
justifiably pissed off because their
sheriff their local police officer
locked them in and used the full might
of the police state against them because
they wanted to live
oath breakers yes and that's why people
are legitimately angry at the police and
and they're going to be angry again
because the officers are still
continuing to listen to those orders
so this is why one one of the reasons
why i voted for trump
um clearly i'm not the biggest trump
supporter in the world but i think he's
infinitely better than joe biden
i think he's done good on foreign policy
we had a big argument know he's
conscious he could talk
well yeah that's for sure joe biden came
what did he say he was like you know if
we get an argument with kamala you know
like i said
obama i'll just say i contracted a
disease and then resigned yes
that's what he would have done as the
vice president he was saying when out he
said he said that in
in a dispute with kamala just like he
said with obama
so what he said was he will he would
have done it with obama and he'll do it
i think he said he would have done with
obama and kamala he wants kamal to do
that with him
no he you would expect her to back off
no no he would say
he said what i would say to her like i
said i don't know if he would said he
would resign if his vice president
i could pull up the clip yeah literally
sounded like it but i think what he
meant was as vp
no no no no we're not playing we're not
playing that game where we could
translate for joe biden that's what the
dude
what idiot what would you say if my vp
didn't just fight joe biden
illness and resign from the presidency
the controversy
i i disagree i'm only questioning his
intention
i know no i think he was making an
allegory from what he would have done as
vp to what his vp would do we could look
up the exact quote
we should look it up but it is but it
just should be surprising to a lot of
people that
joe biden had this biden says he would
resign
if a moral dispute with harris arose in
this quote
from the street certified by newsguard
no
you are well i disagree like i told
barack
if i reach something where there's a
fundamental disagreement we have based
on moral principle i'll develop some
disease and say i have to resign
he said that when he said what he would
tell barack right
like i told barack he was asked how he
would respond to kamala harris and he
said like i told barack
what he said was he would have done with
obama and he'll do it like he told
barack
the vice president would do it with
obama and the vice president would do it
literally that was my interpretation
does it matter you're making that up
he was asked what do you how do you
resolve a dispute with harris
and he said you know if you know i i i i
i i he said that a million times
if i'm in a dispute with harris like i
told barack i'll say i'll develop a
disease and say after resign
he told c anderson cooper that he would
do the same thing he would have known
with obama if harrison have it
i'm not going to waste time arguing this
with you i don't understand how you're
arguing it's a quote
another thing he said the article's
pretty eye opening is
he also announced today that there's
going to be a hundred days of
mass a hundred days listen luke luke he
was in the basement
he didn't know what he didn't realize we
were already wearing masks i know that's
the thing
according to the cdc data most of
americans already wear masks they
haven't stopped wearing masks and this
was even confirmed by the new york times
so so him saying that everything's going
to go back to normal everything's going
to be fine if people just wear a mask
for the next 100 days is is again just
another
delusional crazy thing leave joe alone
man he was in the basement okay
he didn't know what was going on does he
mean like in houses is that what is a
hundred times
between bites in your own home like
california said california's like you
gotta wear a mask in your own home
and and you lift your mask up take bites
and put the mask back on you know i was
tweeted by the official
governor of california twitter account
as uh gavin newsom was literally at that
restaurant
meeting with the california board of
health thousands of
dollars uh spending thousands of dollars
at this restaurant joe biden said he
would resign i'm starting to think
remember i mean kamala literally was
saying
you know this is going to be the great
president can we show this again
i'm not i want to listen to it can i
listen to it this is not what i'm
there's not be let's play let's see if
can we play this
but all kid aside the first lady to be
told me she holds them for you yes she
does
but not with she's because she she and
camel have become friends
but all kidding aside it's it's a matter
of
the thing we are simpatico on our
philosophy of government
and sympatico on how we want to attach
approach these issues that we're facing
and so i don't have and when we disagree
it'll be just like
so far it's been just like when barack
and i did it's in private she'll say i
think we should do a b c or d
and i'll say i don't i like a don't like
b and c and
let's go okay but and i like i told
barack
if if i reach something where there's a
fundamental
disagreement we have based on a moral
principle
i'll uh i'll i'll i'll i'll develop some
disease and say i have to resign
um we don't have that i'm we haven't and
we discussed at length
our views on foreign policy on domestic
polishing
he he was talking about what he would do
not what she and what he would expect
her to do i think
he would say that his ex expectation is
that if the vice president has a deep
philosophical disagreement with him that
why they would resign come on man he
didn't say the words vice
president well he didn't say i would
resign this presidency i mean he wasn't
that specific
like i told barack if i reach something
where there's a fundamentals agreement
where i have based on a moral principle
i'll develop a disease and say i have to
resign yeah as the vice president like
that's what he would have told you
you're making that voice
he's just literally making stuff up well
he wasn't the president with barack what
does that have to do with anything
he would expect the vice president to
resign why is the president negotiating
with the vice president on what they
should or shouldn't be doing in the
first place they're not he just said he
was
he's going to have a private
conversation about what they agree on
and then if it come to disagreement like
he said with barack he'll resign
right you're trying to defend the guy
when he didn't say dude i have no
defense of that idiot first of all
i feel like what they did with franklin
delano roosevelt hiding his polio
for years makes me think that they're
going to hide this guy's illness as long
as that's what they're doing with the
foot man he took his booty off when he
went on the interview
and anderson was like waiting he's just
old and losing his mind i don't think
he's an idiot he's just falling apart
he's the corporate establishment
representative that will say anything
that they give them to read
that's what he's been throughout his
entire have you seen those big
teleprompters where the letters are
really big
yes i feel sorry for the man more than i
do the stain
listen listen listen ian you know that
nancy pelosi
put forth the 25th amendment provision
creating a council
to to determine whether or not because
it's the 24th amendment says
i think it's the 25th right is that what
it was the one it says
that congress has the right to appoint a
you know a group
or whatever or so what nancy pelosi was
saying is
we'll have a panel that will evaluate
the mental fitness of the president and
everyone's like you're doing this to get
rid of trump she says no
it's not for trump it's for a future
president everyone's like it's for biden
we know it's for biden they like listen
everybody was questioning
why joe biden he's 78 he's the oldest
president ever there's no way he can run
for a second term
and now we have a video coming out where
he says if i get a dispute i'll say have
some disease and resign and everyone's
like we know
and then you see kamala they're like
yeah yeah
she's sick and they're saying okay he's
back on track he's back out trying to
it's like she's like got this look
like she's waiting for him to go
she's smiling thinking like soon soon
i tweeted this is really funny i tweeted
um when that thing
story was breaking it would kind of suck
if the first female president was due to
process and not
vote i i stand by that opinion i think
it's true
i think if we want to have a female
president it was it's because the
american people said this is the right
person for the job
and not because somebody dies or is
now infirm and needs to be removed or
but but all these social justice
leftists started
like rapping all over me and attacking
me i'm like you think it's better that
we get a met like by mandate the first
meal president like that's that's bad
historical precedent
and no one supported her in the primary
no one she got no vote no no elect no
no no she is an evil prosecutor
if you look at her police record i mean
oh my
goodness it is deplorable it is insane
to see
how many innocent people had their lives
ruined
because of kamala harris whether she
laughed whether it was smoking marijuana
whether it was crimes that they didn't
commit that she knew
they didn't commit she still put them in
jail threatening
impoverished single mothers with prison
time because their true sons were
missing
yes they didn't go to school because if
their you know children didn't show up
to school
parents would literally face legal
repercussions that they had to fight
in court that led to devastating effects
on family members i'm sorry can you can
we just think about this for a second so
when i was a kid we had kerf we have
curfew in chicago if you're under the
age of 17 cops can
literally just take you and bring you to
your home and then someone has to sign
for you
i thought that was always crazy that
they have something like that but think
about it this way truancy laws are
literally saying
your children must be institutionalized
as we see
otherwise you go to prison when did we
cross that line
that the state can by mandate
institutionalize your children in
california with kamala harris and her
new
yeah and now also today with
a 10 p.m lockdown of 8.5 million
which is happening in california right
now welcome because somehow you won't
get the
the covid virus if it's 10 00 or 10 00
uh
959. ladies and gentlemen pull out your
bingo cards and get ready to check off
the box that box that says
welcome to the nightmare dystopia 8.5
million people are being ordered to
stay home ahead of a california
statewide
orders 10 000 people hospitalized 22 000
daily cases are
recorded 145 deaths in 24 hours this is
in the bay area
and it is just expected to escalate but
i i but i must stop
there is some good news california
sheriffs have come out saying
fu we're not gonna do it ain't gonna
happen i'd love to hear it how do you
how do you break your oath of the
constitution some
surprisingly there are a lot of cops who
do some sheriffs but not all the
sheriffs
there still will be a lot of pointless
ignorant police officers that don't have
a backbone that don't have a soul
that will enforce these orders with the
full might of the police state and one
thing we have to understand here people
changed their lifestyles they lost their
jobs they lost their businesses
they lost their freedoms their kids
can't go to school anymore they
eviscerated and destroyed the working
class and any prosperity any a
ability of freedom for people to have
because of a lockdown and now
it pretty much didn't work but lock down
again do you know what a quarantine is
quarantine is
the closing in of sick people and
preventing sick people from spreading so
what do you call it when instead of
doing that they lock everyone in their
martial law
essentially martial now let's play a
game michael flynn recently tweeted out
the we the people convention
calling on donald trump to invoke
extreme wartime powers
essentially declaring a light martial
law having a new election
and we saw lynn wood we saw sydney
powell we saw many trump supporters echo
this
and the collective screeching from the
left it's
happening there's memes going around
it's the political compass right
and you've got the authoritarian left
the libertarian left and the libertarian
right and they all have shocked and
scared faces
and then you have this like really doofy
looking guy with a maga hat saying
martial law good and then in the middle
it says michael flynn calls for martial
law
and then the libertarian left side is an
anti-looking guy with a bunch of guns
saying we told you so
and i think this is really really funny
because they have been enforcing martial
law on this country for
a year and you supported it and now
you're mad that people are saying
hey donald trump needs to stop this and
something must be done about it yeah and
they voted for it and we're gonna have a
lot more of it with a joe biden
presidency and i'm still shocked how
last year we literally went from storm
area 51
they can't stop us all so right now
let's have
christmas and thanksgiving together uh
they can't arrest us all when we're
lock us in our homes lock us in our
house absolutely insane area 51 event
the event was pretty fun but that's a
different subject lock us in our homes
kevin
yeah terrible protest chant i just made
it up i don't like it go with it
i don't know but we're seeing a lot of
resistance from some sheriffs
we saw a significant protest in staten
island
we're seeing slowly people kind of wake
up and realize that it's kind of
hypocritical to allow black friday but
not thanksgiving
and and people i think i i i might be
naive but i think there's a larger kind
of feeling of discontent of of anger and
frustration at all these politicians
who set up all these rules and don't
follow them but listen listen listen
conservatives aren't complaining about
peaceful protests from black lives
matter
in the sense that they're protesting
they're complaining about the hypocrisy
of demanding lockdowns and then
protestings and then protesting
but there's nary a conservative who's
saying these people are going to get us
all sick they shouldn't be protesting no
they're saying
you have a first amendment right to
protest but how dare you say we should
be locked down and you get to go outside
meanwhile on the left they're saying
we're gonna go celebrate and dance on
the street for joe biden
and then in staten island when the cops
arrest this bar owner and a couple
hundred
just regular people not trump supporters
maybe some of them maybe
but regular people in the community came
out with flags protesting
i'm seeing all these lefties say these
people are going to kill us
i'll tell you what the problem is right
now in this country those people who are
saying this
they don't care about you they don't
care about the law
or the rules or any kind of moral or
ethical standard it's we get
power and you can go to hell
and that's what that's that's what
they're giving us when i see regular
people say
please are struggling and dying we can't
do this anymore and they say
shut your mouth get in your home and
drop to your knees
we're going to go party that's a powder
cag that is about to explode
only a matter of time 100 agree and uh
we went we went to the gun shop the
other day
yeah and i was like i will take that
whole shelf of ammo and that whole thing
was that much left
and the guy was like i understand yeah i
kept telling my friends and family
members in
june it was everything by the way buy
everything you can i mean i'm shocked at
what you guys have here
compared to new hampshire it's
absolutely gone nothing i mean
let's let's let's let's let's put this
into context so we went to we went to a
i don't want to give out details because
i don't want to you know drag anybody
we went to a gun store they don't have
that much ammo a lot of odd caliber
bullets things that like i was like do
you even have guns for this stuff
three times four times even ten times
and it was like as
what i was paying for in june it was
like two boxes per
per like different you know ammo type
except for the 12-gauge stuff that
i was like i went nuts and i was like
well that's still readily available
because
right you know that's still something
that people can get but when it comes to
nine millimeter five five six
you're paying an arm and a leg yeah dude
it's absolutely crazy i mean
for for you know 900 bullets five five
six i was paying a couple hundred
dollars
that's a thousand bucks a thousand bucks
for 900 bullets and i'm like
and and the thing is it's back to normal
soon that's the thing
people think it's going to go back to
normal it's not i love how the guys were
just like yup
like it's not total it's totally normal
like someone comes in and they're like
there's not that much to buy because i i
when i
so dude it's no joke i bring this up in
in earlier this year and i said i don't
want any guns in my house
and then covet happened the pandemic
stuff happened the stalker happened
yesterday
yeah i had a whole bunch of stalkers as
well for sure for sure but like looking
at the stores being picked clean
and like we we had a walmart only like a
mile or so away and i'm like
we're really close to this place and
there's like there's there's no food
people are running in and seizing all
the toilet paper and stuff i'm like we
got to take care of ourselves
and i even had a cop advise me and and
we were really we're in a small suburb
so the playstation wasn't that far away
and he was like
you need to answer your door with a
shotgun when someone comes you know so
that got me thinking but it wasn't until
the riots went nuts and i heard the
helicopters
i went out and bought a bunch of guns
but here's the thing they had no ammo
i remember i went in and i was like i
was talking to the guy and i said i need
45 auto and he goes one box
and i'm like it's 50 50 rounds he's like
all i can do
so i've been to three or four different
shops there's one shop
where they said you get one of each box
and it's crazy too because the 22
it's like 50 it's a little tiny box i'm
like what am i going to do with this and
you're lucky
i know i know that's why when we went to
that one store i was like
i will take it all and they're like no
limit sir we understand yes here's a box
it was marked up pretty heavily but
they're going to keep going up
uh and we have to understand here this
is something that a lot of people are
finding very troublesome
i mean even from like an investment
point of view if you bought bullets and
firearms in
in june and july you you could sell it
you'd be making
to make a crap ton of money just on that
initial investment and some people
legitimately are
but there is a lack of a lot of this
stuff because people are buying it
whenever they can because they know
either one something major is going to
happen two they know that there's going
to be an administration that's going to
try to take it away from people
um remember remember the story about the
red flag laws when they started coming
out where
someone could basically report you as
being unwell and the cops show up your
house and say we're seizing your guns
there was a story i think it was
baltimore some guy gets a the
cops up to his house he he says you know
who they say with the police he opens up
and they say we're here to take your
guns and he says
not a chance the cops fight with them
cops shoot and kill him these there are
people who will
absolutely say no to the police who try
to violate the constitution
now that's scary it's i understand it
for sure what's scary about it is
we are dangerously close when we know
for a fact these states are violating
the constitution why because supreme
court's already ruled in states like
michigan and pennsylvania
and then says that california are still
doing it or when the supreme court sides
with
worship religious institutions under the
first amendment did you
did you read i think it was gorsuch his
opinion
there's no version of reality where
you're you can have tanning salons and
liquor stores remain open but people
can't go to church
that that was bold yeah but they issue
that and then what does cuomo say so
what we'll do it again
and can you do it one other thing that
people have to realize here when you
look at the strictest
toughest most unfair lockdowns that rob
people of their livelihoods they are
mainly happening in democratic cities
where people don't have the right to
defend themselves and are not armed
you look at what happened in canada and
australia where there was recently
gun legislation that limited people's
ability to defend themselves
what happened the canadian government
and australian government are
absolutely having a heyday with just
making up whatever made up decrees
not even based off on the science not
even any logic
but they're locking people down in
extreme ways arresting people
meanwhile allowing black lives matter
protests check this out but
check us the other day uh when we had
destiny here
he said we need a two-month lockdown
everybody should get paid
and the issue was we ended up coming
back to it and i said didn't we already
lock down
and he was like not nationwide but hold
on europe they locked down
they closed their borders and it all
came back why did it come back
well because we ease the restrictions so
you're saying that no matter what we do
kovit is here to stay there's nothing we
can do about it we can't live this way
we can't there's it's physically
impossible to stay this this way
unless they just want people to die they
want people to starve become evicted
get depressed commit suicide dependent
on government uh go
but but no but listen yes to an extent
being dependent on government
but at a certain point there's no food
on the shelves unless someone puts it
there or makes it exactly and if no one
is working there is nothing to be given
to people
politics is a popularity contest we got
stupid people
running in the show as well as
government mandates that literally
slaughtered
chickens pigs got rid of and thrown out
did you see vegetables and fruits that
were available for everyone
but all of those i mean i was in touch
with some farmers across
the united states they were ordered
destroy everything you have
the supply chain has been cut this is
the best thing you could do it's
absolutely insane and now there's food
shortages and now we have to understand
the effects of these lockdowns are not
leading to more suicides like we just
saw in japan in japan more people killed
themselves
than died from uh covet 19 and
around the world especially in desolate
places in third world countries hunger
is becoming more of a rapid epidemic but
we keep
we keep being told by these politicians
no we're going to do another lockdown it
didn't work the first time but it's
going to work now
oh we're going to do more masks they
didn't really work but we're going to do
them
more now oh we're going to wait until
the vaccine comes again everything the
politicians have been saying about this
have been absolutely
wrong and i think it's extremely
dangerous coming forward
with the establishment yes everything
the establishment said because
trump said schools should remain open
yes and they said he was nuts he wanted
to kill your kids
now and they said he was nuts when he
tried to shut down travel from from
cenophobia and they were keep they keep
going back and forth there's no
consistency there's no logic
and a lot of times they just lie to you
through their teeth they're telling you
just hold on a little bit longer
everything's going to be fine just just
give us a few more weeks just give us a
hundred days of masks
you want to you want to know what a
lockdown the vaccines are coming they're
going to fix everything don't you want
to you want to know why
you want i can give you the perfect
example of why i
cannot stand the democrats listen today
there was a vote in the house on
legalizing cannabis that's what i'm
talking about and guess who voted for it
ron paul no no no just the party which
party was for it democrats
democrats that's right who's opposed to
it republican republican
republicans in my opinion are just i'm
it's trash
okay donald trump is very different and
i think most trump supporters recognize
that many of these republicans are just
crony establishment but hold on hold on
at least they at at at least
they're doing very little and they're
kind of ineffectual
what you got you got something to say
about republicans doing something else
um i have i
i wanted to finish my point by
specifically saying there's too many
too many people profiting off of these
lockdowns
off of these restrictions for them to
end anytime soon so we have to
understand there's another factor here
that that we have to understand that
that that when it comes to the
billionaires when it comes to the
establishment when it comes to the
ruling class they're getting
way too many benefits from this lockdown
for it to do the vaccine
company is going to make tons of money
pfizer is set to make a lot of money but
we have
billions we also have to understand this
is a company that literally
just came out yesterday and they said
that
quote this is the chairman of pfizer
we're not sure if someone can transmit
the virus
if they take the back seat and and this
is you know what's the
company because they want everyone to
take it because
well everybody might be vaccinated right
you could still get sick
again this is there's he's saying
there's no hurt immunity with the
vaccine that's what he's saying
which means everybody must get it or he
doesn't know if there is yeah
which means everybody must get it so
apparently
somebody google this google somebody
super chatted saying one of the
proposals going through right now is
that the stimulus will only go to those
who get vaccinated whoa what
there are proposals by some democrats
saying that if you want to receive the
new stimulus checks
there is some writings in some of the
legislation has hasn't passed but it's
being proposed and it's being talked
about and it wouldn't surprise me
and there will be a certificate uh that
people will be getting
after getting this vaccine which was
officially announced today as well but
we have to understand here pfizer
i think you're right i think he's making
that statement to make sure more people
have this general idea that they need
this thing but when it comes to pfizer
one they're not facing any liability
surrounding this but this is a company
that paid out close to five billion
dollars
since 2000 in damages and fines
to individuals to organizations and to
governments for corruption
this time they can't do that and listen
listen listen
i know a lot of people want to make it
about the vaccine but this is about
transfer of wealth
what they want is we want carte blanche
for the government to transfer taxpayer
dollars to us with zero liability and
that's what they are getting
not just them but these other companies
too but let's and then i just want to go
off on a little tangent here because
this is going to be the largest
vaccine program that the united states
has ever had and has ever dealt with and
i think it's also important to look back
in history
especially in american history at the
latest
vaccine program that was the largest
before this one and it was the 1976
swine flu the h1n1 vaccine
that 25 percent of americans got in a
10-month span
this was because one u.s soldier at fort
dix in new jersey
came down with the h1n1 swine flu and
the government then decided to have a
full-scale response everyone's going to
get a vaccine we're going to fast
track it we're going to move forward
we're going to make sure that no one
gets this h1n1 that we found at fort dix
new jersey with this one
u.s soldier dying what happened with
this vaccine program
it was very unnecessary
because what year was it 1976
because the virus h1n1 never left
fort dix no one else was affected by
this
but they still vaccinated 25 percent
of americans in a 10-month span and
the vaccine was found to have links with
galen
barine syndrome which has injured
yes which is i'm saying that wrong has
injured a large number of individuals
all of it
totally unnecessary totally made up
because a politician
said he's going to help everyone said
he's going to fix everything
we've got it we got we got the official
source i've got discover
discover magazine certified news guard
and there's a quote
the swine flu program was marred by a
series of logistical problems ranging
from the production of the
wrong vaccine strain to a confrontation
over liability protection
to a temporal connection of the vaccine
and a cluster of deaths among the
elderly population in pittsburgh
sound familiar yes exactly the most
damning charge against the vaccination
program was that the shots were
correlated with an increase in the
number of patients diagnosed with an
obscure neurological disease
known as gelane bar syndrome is that you
pronounce it guillain-barre there you go
you see he can't pronounce it neither
can i
so look this was the largest vaccine
program in the united states and now
we're about to go through another one
i'm not saying that there's any
correlation or any mixes extremely
different circumstances
but it's important to understand here
that there is history with the united
states
doing okay human experience
is it fair to say that i think we've
made substantive developments in the 44
years
since 1976 right there have been many
important developments with
big pharma that has helped a lot of
people there's no denying
that but when it comes to holding this
industry accountable i think there needs
to be a lot more oversight
a lot more scrutiny and a little bit
more skepticism because there isn't
now is it fair to label it all bad no
um i would i'm gonna show you an article
go ahead
from market watch wall street and
finance workers could get coveted
vaccines before most americans
doesn't prove anything again no no no no
no no no no no no
wait wait go go go if if you think
there's some risk here don't worry
they're giving it to wall street
financiers first
i say give it to the government
officials first i think that would solve
all of our problems
look i really do mean it when i say i'm
not obama
bush and some other person are lined up
to get the vaccine it's clinton so
bill clinton the guy who said he didn't
have relations with that woman
barack obama who drank the water from
flint right
and the guy who told us that there was
weapons of mass destruction
are now going to tell me that they're
taking this shot that we don't know what
it is
i hope again one thing that we have to
understand here is
again we can't just paint everything
black and white we can't
just say everything's good and bad there
is important
middle ground there is gray zones that
we need to look into that we need to
consider
but i do truly believe that we are aware
of all the positive sides but not of the
negative sides and people need to be
aware the united states has a long
history of
going after human beings that didn't
know what was happening
and experimenting with them with medical
procedures
i could list off your future i have here
but okay
experiment for sure can i get into this
list i mean we have the cia lsd
experiments that led to people dying
that was kind of
the tostiga experiments that happened to
hundreds of individuals and as they were
dying as they became blind as they
became insane
because of syphilis that was given to
them by
a u.s government grant they decided not
to treat it and this was all funded by
u.s taxpayers
in 1953 through 1954 and 1963 to 1965
st louis was literally sprayed with
radioactive
particles in order to conduct a military
test
agent orange in vietnam depleted uranium
in iraq
the 1948 operation sea spray project
112. again i could keep going on and on
there are so many instances where the
u.s government literally
unsuspecting citizens just said we're
just going to
test you with all this different stuff
there's going to be a lot of negative
consequences but we're going to cover it
my mom was telling me this is a
philosophical question here go ahead
it's it's deontological versus
utilitarian
do you think the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few it depends
on the situation
that's very hard to say that's a very
blank generalized statement quote from
what star trek two i think was i don't
know maybe
the many are destroying everything then
no
so if so the the needs of them right so
you're so that's exactly the mentality
not when it comes to
disability or saving the situation then
yes unsuspecting american citizens and
testing them with
uh ddt and syphilis no
i'm saying right now let's say that uh
there is
a a you know an increase in certain
syndromes
like uh how do you pronounce it again
gianray
guillain-barre
so one of the arguments when there was
that big remember that movie vaxxed came
out or whatever
yes i actually went to uh the cdc and
had a big conversation with a lot of
people there
and they were very much like this is
ridiculous and one of the things that i
said
that said was they were like i want you
to think about something let's say that
one
in 300 000 people do develop
a very severe negative symptom now when
they do
it's not always like permanent paralysis
it could just be
a like a minor thing right if it does
is it worth saving the lives of three
million people if it means that 30
will end up getting some kind of
negative impact it's like the questions
we have to ask
are very difficult yes because we
recognize that we want to maximize good
we want to do the right by most people
but it means when you're looking at
people like numbers
you'll see that they're going to be
people who suffer but what do you do
help no one no
you're honest you don't lie to people
you tell them the risks that are
involved
with getting this experimental vaccine
that history and medical science has
never seen before you tell the people
what they're getting themselves into
and i was going to ask you the same cdc
that's tied in with special interest
the same cdc that keeps changing their
official point of view and stance on the
covid virus everything is about
everything there's a balance i mean
there is
look there is a balance we deserve a lot
more truth we deserve a lot more
accountability we deserve a lot more
information and we're not getting it
we're getting lies by government
officials who think they're better and
more important and could tell us and
lecture us
that we don't need masks when they work
when they want to know there's two kinds
of people right now there are two kinds
of people
one that says i trust the government
wholeheartedly no matter what
that's insane and the other that say i
never trust the government at all
but in between is the real gradient of
people who say
there are certain things i trust in
certain things i don't certainly people
would say i trust the troops
right depends on what's they're
absolutely here in afghanistan
and if you're not i'm talking about
american citizens do you trust the
government luke hell no
but would you trust a a a service man
who said it depends i don't know him
if there was a guy any and you pop in
your car and he stopped and says there's
a raging wildfire ahead please don't go
down that way we're trying to get it
secure we're saving lives
would you trust them it depends on the
circumstance and situation i would
actually
see the fact check it out there's smoke
coming up and they said stop stop stop
if you go there you'll die we can't let
you do this
am i escaping other government agents
not to throw me into female camps listen
is he wearing a badge what i'm saying is
at the end of the day everybody chooses
who and what they trust of course
and there are some people that say to
all those things
yes they happened because the government
in the united states has done horrifying
things and many on the left protest a
lot of these things
but not anymore protesting right it goes
back and forth
yeah well i've never learned about it in
school or anything i had to find out
talks about how the us government treats
its citizens like just
gerbils that they could do whatever they
want with another issue to really
consider and to really talk about is
gain of
function data when we're looking at the
studies that happen with scientists and
the military coming together saying
let's weaponize this virus
as much as we can let's see how deadly
we can make it
for absolutely no reason at all let's
finance this research
let's even let's make sure it happens in
wuhan uh let's let's make sure we study
this crazy pathogen and and let's bring
them all together let's be mad
scientists let's create a virus that
could destroy the world
why why are we doing this why is this
this because
why do they make nuclear weapons there
have been no scientific breakthroughs
that have actually worked and have
actually helped
uh whether it comes to science or modern
medicine through gain of functions
gain of function is testing like the the
danger of something it's making it as
dangerous as possible
for potential weaponized purposes there
have been no scientific
findings that have actually helped the
scientific community it's literally
playing with god
that's what the government playing with
god playing playing god sorry playing
god
and and thinking that you know you could
create something that could essentially
wipe us all out for
for what for what reason for war exactly
against that like how do you defend it i
would argue that the government's a
little bit too big and powerful and i
think we should step it back a little
bit
are you are you going to ignore china of
course i'm not going to ignore so
i've been talking about china for a very
long time yes yes yes listen um
this is this is the the very serious and
inherent problem with
coming up and pulling out all the worst
possible things the united states has
done
because if you pulled up a list of say
all the worst puzzle things china has
done you'd be like wow i really trust
the americans gain a function
studies have been done in part
participation yes with the united states
yes and china
in wuhan and china was smuggling in
viruses and they got caught by the state
department yes and bill barr mike pompeo
they've been talking about this there
have been many arrests the point is
look man like i said there's two kinds
of people some people will look at
everything the united states has ever
done and say don't trust the government
and they
don't have a view out many of these
people don't have you outside of the
united states and realize
that there are there are other way worse
things the point is
what i'm saying is you've got to find
reasonable balance
you don't want to blindly trust anybody
you don't want to blindly trust the
government like the shirt you said
yesterday if you trust the government
you haven't learned you learned from
history
and they say those who who forget
history are doomed to repeat it
at the same time what if what we're
experiencing
is the other conspiracy that china
was was the one who manufactured
something like this and then the u.s is
desperately trying to defend us
and then you're actively opposing that
well though the point is a very
convenient
line that no no it's not convenient it's
it's you don't know we don't know
exactly because they're not honest and
they're not transparent and they're so
this is why i say the best thing you can
do is first i think everything they're
doing
right now i find uh uh what the gov what
the government is with the lockdown's
completely wrong
yeah in terms of should we social
distance
yes i i don't have a big problem with
that we could deal with this in a
practical way that deals with the
elderly
that deals with this making a vaccine i
don't high five tim
anymore let's listen what's that no more
high fives that's the worst
listen listen they're not coming out and
giving you the vaccine you can't
actually get i don't know that yet no we
do see what's happening in canada you
see what you've seen the the
chief medical officer in ontario just
announced that if someone refuses to
take the vaccine
the covid19 vaccine they won't have
freedom to move
around that's what i'm saying today by a
official government that has disarmed
their i am
not a fan of mandated medication by
anybody
i am not a fan of all the massive
corporations just going along with it
and if you think
democrats won't force it on you if you
think como and other crazy individuals
that are already
robbing you blind won't do it on you
it's not it's a little bit naive let me
be honest here
you think the government can actually
pass a law the government is already in
an insane
level where they are telling people when
they could leave their house
the government is already telling people
that they can't drive their car by
themselves that's an issue they're
telling their people that they can't
even
have a paddle board in the middle of the
ocean by themselves
that's what the government is enforcing
right now police who are breaking theirs
of the constitution but that's because
of politicians telling them how to do so
and it we already reached the insane
level we already reached a crazy level
and if you think it's going to subside
from here with all the power that was
granted to these psychopaths
mostly psychopaths i mean it's it's not
going to happen the issue in power
they love it they want more of it all
this comes down to
is that we have a growing escalation
between
china yes chinese infiltration the
democrats who are clearly breaking their
own rules and don't even believe their
own rules
the world economic forum and this
election and this
is the point i'm making about the
explosive potter cat we're sitting on
because you can talk about all this
stuff and you know why it's so
frustrating
you have no answer to any of this i do
know what's what's your answer make
memes
uh make your euro start your own farm
that won't change anything
when you come out where you come out and
say when you come out and say no to the
us government
and then open the door to china it
depends no no you don't have to open the
door to china
you don't have to you don't have to you
have to be aware of both of these issues
you have to be aware of china on the
geopolitical world stage and how they
want to be the predominant world power
that is a big threat
i have acknowledged it we have talked
about it extensively i 100 agree so what
do you do here in the united states to
deal with that you know you've been
living this what have you
what are you doing right now no no what
do you do right now i'm self-sufficient
right as i've had you learn how to farm
you learn how to defend yourself you
learn how to use firearms which i've
been doing at extreme levels this entire
year you learn how to defend
yourself and to live outside of any
government control any government
influence how will that allow a cohesive
strategic response to what we're seeing
from china well we're not going to have
a cohesive response right now with the
presidency that i agree i know what they
what we agree completely agree i believe
biden is the capitulation to china i
think what the democrats are doing is
detestable because they're clearly not
found they're on lockdown rules yeah so
the issue is
how do we actually deal with it when
instead if listen
yeah no there's there's no good answer
other than
the keg is going to explode and
everybody has a different opinion on
what they think must be done
so right now people what do you think
must be done i i agree with you on the
self-sufficiency part
buying the ammo learning how to how to
take care of yourself
being responsible for yourself and i've
i've often felt that way for the most
for most part of my life right now we
are in we're entering a period where
i've repeatedly said
and quoting a ton of other people we are
we are either off the cliff in terms of
polarization
the ceo of axios that the united states
is decoupling it is it is to the point
where
you bring this stuff with a stuff up
with a vaccine first and foremost
you can mention swine flu stuff i can
pull this up i totally recognize all of
this
but i think most people are going to be
completely fine
because they're rolling it out through
the elderly first the medic the people
who've gotten the placebos
then the medical workers then uh the
most vulnerable people who are at risk
of dying either way
yes but we have to understand there's
another conundrum here that a lot of
people aren't realizing
what's happening in china china right
now is fine
totally fine unaffected by this so all
the news we're getting out of china is
from the chinese government so
well at the same time we're getting
images of thousands of people without a
mask
we got footage of the muslim camps yeah
but we get footage out of china but what
what happened what's going on in africa
africa is not being as devastated by the
sickness as the worst of the world
there's there's something that
absolutely just doesn't make sense
that's not that's not necessarily man
they eat no they're not sugar
indoctrinated that's not necessarily
true
no one is going there and tracking any
of this there's no great big hospitals
writing all the numbers down now i did a
segment on the john hopkins university
newsletter
that said this this reporter her name is
dr i believe brienne
that when she looked at the
year-over-year data she doesn't see a
major spike and
said she believed that heart disease
deaths were down and covadas were up
leading to what she believed was an
over-exaggeration but still
a lot of people will look the reason why
this is so frustrating
is that everybody makes the leap of
assumption
they say if we're not hearing about
africa that's it
and then there's no consideration as to
why that might be so people are saying
they deleted this letter that proves
they're censoring hiding it we're not
getting data out of africa that proves
it it's not real or china
or like you mentioned china could be
lying they could be welding people's
doors
apparently nothing's going on or it
could be that the democrats
are overreacting refuse to accept
responsibility and are exploiting this
for political gain
they wanted an excuse for no you know
excuse mail in voting
they got it there's a million in one
reasons it is so difficult to break down
first and foremost the most important
thing you can do is be self-sufficient
rely on yourself take care of yourself
and do simple things to keep yourself
safe that are within certain reasonable
boundaries
social distancing wearing a mask is
totally reasonable like nationwide
lockdowns and statewide stay home orders
completely unreasonable destroying
everything
i think i think it's legitimate to start
the conversation and and ask
those questions and to see wait what's
going on in africa what's going on in
china
because we are seeing a very unorthodox
situation where i think we should
question everything
where i think we should always be asking
accountability but asking accountability
from our government is not the same as
letting china win
you know we're not letting china win by
holding our government accountable or to
a higher standard
america wins when america is strong
honest
and and has its people in the know of
exactly what's going on because when the
people know what's going on
we're able to prepare and we're able to
make
moves in our lives that makes us safe
in the future rather than completely
unsafe completely unprepared and i was
going to
family-friendly show here i'm not going
to say the
well-informed population is a
decentralized network will compute
correct answers more
uh more accurate than a single
individual who thinks they're smarter
and we're not informed
there's a lot of lies there's a lot of
bull crap no this it's it's also large
elements of the government it's also
large elements of the education system
it's also large elements of the
entertainment system
establishing the distraction bread and
circus system that we have to deal with
and i think
criticizing it is essential to making it
better not making
china win in some kind of circumstance
or way but i think
us standing up holding our government
accountable and saying you did this this
and this
make this right fix this tell us the
truth right now will lead
us towards a path towards of success
rather than capitulation towards china
and
so so what would satisfy you with the
pfizer vaccine
let's release all the data right now
about the trials
we're not getting any information
regarding the troubles that some
individuals are having
there's a lot of data that's absolutely
being hidden from the general public
about what happened during these studies
the exact
data the numbers the the details i want
to know all of it and i think we should
know all of it exactly what's happening
but we're being told
complications there's some complications
with some people what what is the
complication
i want liability for some of these
companies i want to make sure that
there's some
way if they egregiously go overboard and
abuse their power like they have before
that there is some kind of system where
there could be some retribution
for a horrible act now i'm saying they
still need legal protection
they still need to be protected in a way
because if if they face
too much liability they won't be able to
do anything but there's a middle ground
towards being egregious towards hurting
people and knowing you're going to hurt
people right
there's a there's a middle question go
ahead should people get the vaccine
um again
everyone has their own life and they
should educate themselves
about this about this issue and make
their own decision for themselves
uh i'm not in a place to tell people
what to do
i wouldn't be telling people what to do
i would tell people to do their research
do their homework
and when the data comes out and
hopefully we find out exactly what's
happening during these trials which
are not right now then i think we can
make a better decision but until that
happens uh
until tell me the good things about tell
me some good news about the vaccine
i don't know uh i mean they're they're
talking about how this is
a first of its kind that has never
existed
that will essentially trick your body
into thinking that this has and if
they're
in it okay let's play devil's advocate
here if this is an incredible medical
breakthrough
if this is something that helps people i
will be the first one to say
after the data comes out that this is
something that's that's good
so right now that yeah but there's a
possibility there's a possibility for
either way yes
tons of public information saying it's
good very little saying it's bad
you've chosen the negative side of
things no i've chosen to look at history
as an example of what could potentially
happen
and i've chosen to understand that
either outcome could happen
and i'm telling people do the research
before making that very important
decision for yourself
what do you research what do you read
what you mean
like to figure out i feel like i'm being
interrogated right now you know what you
are
you because i'll tell you this where's
the bible because you put my hand on the
bible just hold up on your phone
because the issue i see is yes you can
tell me every negative thing in the
world but you can't tell me anything
that's positive
well no i just told you in this in this
podcast i told you that there have been
medical breakthroughs
by big pharma that have had a
substantial amazing effect on
individuals dealing
with issues that's never no no no i
mentioned both
no no i mentioned both i mentioned that
there have been amazing incredible
findings by
big pharma that would have never
happened if it wasn't for them that have
helped a large number of people
have there been also abuse abuses with
the opioid epidemic
hell yes but the only way to provo to
prevent so
what could someone research to make sure
they're making the right choice
um that's a very good question i would
look at
the first official line of version of
events
that the government says let's see what
they say let's see what
pfizer says let's see the claims that
they're making here
now let's test it on the backdrop of
people who criticize them people who are
the most vocal about it and then you
have two sets of data
and then you're going to make up your
mind whether you like this one or that
one
based off experience based off time
based off events that unfold i had
someone email me
telling me that there's a secret war
going on in frankfurt over security
servers
yes dominion voting machines and when
they do research that's what they find
well exactly the problem is the problem
is people choose
who and what they trust exactly there's
no denying i'm not denying that
so ultimately what it comes down to is
talk to your doctor and if you don't
trust your doctor well then you gotta
find out
my ultimate question is to use reason
logic and multiple sources multiple
doctors
have you ever gotten a vaccine um
i'm not sure because when i came to this
country as
as as an immigrant i'm not sure if i got
vaccinated or not i think i i i listen
to this i got tested for my vaccines i
had my blood drawn and they said that i
have no
kind of i understand i understand
everybody was a little kid
the concerns over the speed at which the
vaccine is being put out are shared by
democrats
like i mentioned before it's you know i
think it was like biden kamala and cuomo
were all like i'm not going to trust
this thing i'm going to wait a little
while
and then there was a bunch of stories
that came out through like cnn saying
when polls come out
most people like a little bit less than
half say they're willing to wait
40 of medical professionals are saying
that they're going to wait as well
right and i think so i'm bringing that
to logical thing to do to be to be fair
the other issue i have is i received
when i mentioned this before when i
traveled
like five vaccines in one day and as far
as i can tell
maybe something happened i don't know
maybe it made me really smart and
successful with youtube i haven't
spiderman i seem to be fine healthy
strapping young lad feel great feel
great uh life's good
and and the issue is recognizing the
speed at which this one's being brought
out and
the shared the bipartisan concerns over
the rate at which it was produced that's
a normal thing people have
it's like should i have not have trusted
going to the doctor the last time
when the doctor says this is what we're
going to do trust me no one says i
didn't i no one said that
what do you mean there's a lot of people
who say that yeah like there's tons of
whole movement of people crazy stuff
right of course but even if you look at
you know vaxxed
their position wasn't all vaccines are
bad it was
some of them are rushed some of them
should be done at a longer interval some
of them should
wait especially if babies are receiving
them and it was
acknowledged that some vaccines are
actually good for you
i think i don't know if you watched vax
but but there was an element of that
that i think is
you know important to look at and to
examine yourself what an individual what
i've learned about older the older
vaccines not this one which is an rna
vaccine apparently they don't put the
virus in it
they give you something new which so
research rna vaccines and find out um
but the old vaccines what they do is
they take blood and then they'd filter
the virus into the blood
but they could only make the filters so
small because they had to let the virus
through
so other things that were the same size
as the virus or smaller would get
through the filter
and sometimes you get tainted vaccines
as a result
so that's not so you're saying this
improvement could keep contaminants and
things like that maybe
i'm not saying you know i want to i want
to shill
for pfizer i i think what my my
what i think about this is i don't my
immediate personal bias assumption is
that it's not a great breakthrough it's
them pulling out the old vaccine and
being like we could easily crank
something up for
a chronovirus we're going to make so
much money off these dumb people the
governments are going to transfer all
their wealth right into our pockets
if you were told to take it now would
you take it now the vaccine yes i
already said no
okay are you okay with pfizer settling
out five
billion dollars since 2000 against uh
damages and fines
am i okay with that yeah yes i am um
are you okay with them not having any
ability what's what's what's the revenue
cap for for pfizer um i don't know i
have to look it up are you okay with not
with them having no liability okay good
so we're on the same page
in order to talk about the five billion
dollar in settlements for pfizer first
of all
i think big pharmaceutical companies are
mostly detestable in in many different
ways
but uh the market cap could simply be
settlements based on people making
claims that's a nuisance fee
and when you add that up to the fact
that they're extremely massive is what
you get
but i think they're for the most part
trash yeah and
along with many of these other big
companies i think they're like the
like look the issue i have
is for one i share the concerns of many
of these other democrats who have come
out and said
you know they're gonna wait a little bit
but i've also looked at the news where
they're like guess what you can't get it
okay i don't like private mandate where
they're like you can't come in unless
you do
especially when they're saying that
younger people aren't even gonna have
access to it anyway
so they're gonna go through this big
list of people before anyone my age or
any of us are allowed to even get it
because they're prioritizing they're
giving it to the uk before they give it
to us
so it's not an issue of what i take it
now it's i guess i'll just wait and see
how things play out i guess
but i don't take the flu shot either i'm
i'm young it's not a big issue they
advise you to do it
but people don't do it all right i don't
like these big corporations and the
thing i hate the most about it
is that the government gives no-bid
contracts and guarantees billions of our
dollars to
them and then for one cuts their
liability
yeah so they're gonna get free cash out
of our pockets it is the largest
transfer of wealth the way
the way i put it is there's only so much
i can do man yeah
i can't listen listen i can't read
anybody's minds i have to trust who i
trust
and when i was traveling the world and i
had to go to the doctor they said
you can get the vaccines or just say no
and i'm like i have to trust my doctor
it's the best i can do when i broke my
hand he fixed it
when uh you know when i when i go to the
hospital for a kidney stone man they
they stitch me right up
and when they said we want to make sure
you don't get yellow fever we're gonna
give you the shot i said all right let's
do it
so when it comes to this stuff in much
the same way it's a large massive
multinational corporation you know that
produces this stuff
i'm not a fan of them i have concerns
about them but what am i supposed to do
it's frustrating to me when it's like
people screaming at from both sides
about some position you have to take and
you can't actually know and the best
thing you can do is just trust your
doctor
demand petition bring up these issues
have a conversation about it i mean we
could lose hope on everything
i choose not to i do think that the will
of the people absolutely matters because
if it didn't they did they wouldn't need
all the propaganda there is still an
extensive
the worst propaganda used against people
because all hope
hope isn't lost yet this this 1976 swine
flu thing yes
the worst thing about it was the
correlation between this and the glean
barrier syndrome how do you pronounce it
diane beret just say it really quickly
and then you know is that like
maxwell so so that's that's what
discover magazine.com said this
correlation
but was the is there right now this like
do you know what the middle light is
no go ahead you don't yeah children of
thalidomide that was when we didn't
start the fire yes that's right when
their arms were like this
it was a drug there are issues that come
with medication all the time
and so it's it's it's it's worrying it's
like it's it's
not working it's frustrating when people
just highlight only the worst possible
things of something and it's a challenge
because
if we have some kind of medication
that's going to save lives
and there is a fraction of a percentage
that will have severe
you know dangerous side effects and then
you tell all of these people and then
everyone just says i'm not going to do
it and then people end up dying
you have to make sure that the disease
is not worse than the cure and the cure
is not worse than the disease
solving for that is extremely difficult
it's ridiculously difficult
but the government's cure towards
coronaviruses
the lockdowns and many no that's the
democrats and many people are a
political agenda
well it depends it depends on what state
we're exactly looking at but mainly
democrats you're right
but when we look at some of the
statistics the suicides the depression
the job losses the diseases right some
people say that
the the supposed cure towards this is
going to hurt a lot more people
so this is not contentious enough we
need to talk about jeffrey epstein no no
no no no vaccines have a long history of
being absolutely incredible and amazing
and eradicating diseases and saving
humans from torturous
demise lockdown to the history of
breaking everything and ruining
everybody's lives and
not solving the problem in the least bit
exactly so when i look at a vaccine i'm
like i don't like the the liability
protections
i don't like the guaranteed no-bid
contract kind of things but vaccines
for the most part uh i would say
overwhelmingly effective helpful
and what more can any of us do their
lockdowns don't work
they don't work we've got half the
country that are freaking out and crying
in their homes refusing to participate
we could do a lot
we can have a whole health initiative
where people actually have a real
discussion about diet
about health about exercise about
vitamin d about zinc
about taking care of yourself and being
the strongest version of yourself that
you could be but we don't hear any of
that because
that takes away money from big pharma
we're hearing about it from it we're
hearing it now luke
preach it's not just taking money away
from big pharma
it is body positivity right there there
was a woman an influencer who lost a
bunch of weight was smiling that's
insane
and that stuff is absolutely crazy and
some people say it should be mental
illness because it's leading to people
getting hurt
and people are glorifying you and that's
absolutely crazy here's what i was
trying to talk about
from the ghetto before before when i
said
the reason why i don't like the
democrats is they're locking everything
down
people are suffering we're having these
debates over why the government is
guaranteeing
these liability protections as well as
all this money from our from our pockets
amazon is giving us money and i simply
say to the democrats
why are you doing it and you know the
response is the response is
biden ache seeks to ease concerns about
cabinet diversity
welcome to the modern era yeah what are
they concerned about
what is what was joe biden answering
questions who's yellow are you kidding
me
joe biden was asked as a press
conference not about
the economy okay he was he was asked a
lot about a lot a lot a lot of stuff
but why is it that there is
this is this is this is this is the
issue i this is one of the big issues
those people aren't our leaders
our leaders exist in other realms than
politics what's that i actually have
something contentious to say about this
because
we're talking about them talking about
the diversity of joe biden's
cabinet but we're not talking about them
legalizing marijuana and i also feel
like that is a huge bread and circus's
distraction
from the real issues that we're actually
facing why right now
i don't think it's good timing i just
don't agree with the timing there are
people crazy there are people in this
country who are more concerned with the
color of the individuals the race of the
individuals
uh who are standing next to joe biden
and those are those those are the
questions
they want to have between their legs or
what they decide to put inside i was
thinking today about physical health
about kind of what you're talking about
and like why won't biden come out and
tell people to cut sugar out of their
diet
like is it too hard for people is it he
just doesn't
have to understand modern science has
been
used by many special interests to push
certain agendas just like the sugar
industry going against
fats just like the big tobacco industry
financing a lot of doctors
there's a long story of not just yeah
there's there's a new meme going around
showing that doctors should should have
uh
their their medical jackets covered with
all the big pharma
i mean sponsoring them just like
politicians
have you know their logos of the po of
the corporations that support them on
their suits
um so i i do think there's also that
element that needs to be
also recognized that there have been
scientists that have been bought out
by the special interest and said absurd
things like cigarettes are good for you
uh that have absolutely been proven
wrong everything's broken
yeah yeah and it deserves the highest
amount of criticism if we're gonna move
forward in some way
towards fixing it i think for one uh i
was listening to a video from jordan
peterson recently
uh prager you posted it it was someone
asking about climate change and
effective leaders and jordan said clean
your room bucko
that's a simple you know paraphrasing of
what he said was but what actually said
was
i would uh he said something to the
effect of i would be skeptical of
somebody
who was trying to clean the world when
they have not put their own home
before they've taken care of their own
personal affairs
and he said so what we need is for
people to become responsible
self-sufficient to to straighten out
their lives
before they you know eventually move on
to try and change others but
in learning how to be responsible
self-reliant
uh independent they gain those abilities
to then move on to the next step of
helping others do the same to become a
leader
to make appropriate decisions so it all
starts with you
learning how to start a fire yeah how to
start a fire
i should not practice that i mean really
that was a big thing
this year has been huge for me when it
comes to everything that you're
mentioning right now specifically
just being stuck inside of new york city
during the supposed
worst of it during the middle of the
lockdowns during the middle of the
highest supposed epidemic and
realizing that i'm surrounded by a bunch
of unprepared individuals
that are hungry who are hungry and
thirsty will do anything to survive
we're living right on top of each other
and it just takes the trucks not coming
in
that's it you know the bigger madness
but you know the big issue is
the it's there's an optimism and a
normalcy bias so the optimism biases it
can't happen here
the normalcy biases that'll never happen
but people don't realize
when it came to say you know the fall of
the soviet union people had been living
their whole lives
generations under the system then one
day was gone there are civil wars that
broke out where people thought would
never happen in fact in the united
states civil war
people were gathering on the hill near
was at fort sumner thinking a war will
never break out having a picnic
and then also they watch people getting
disemboweled in explosions and we're
like vomiting up their picnic like
wow it's really happening yeah people
people think
you know what's funny is you ever watch
a prepper show yes
and it's funny how people mock and
ridicule peppers you know that was
always confusing to me
you'd think a consumerist capitalist
society would venerate
preppers buy more buy 30 years of beans
and put them in your basement
buy buy buy after 911 happen george w
bush what did he say
um store up uh go buy go purchase go to
the mall go buy stuff
buy stuff that's why i always found it
funny that preppers were looked down
upon if anything that consumerist
americans they were targeted they were
laughed at but this year
in 2020 they're laughing at us they came
out as the real mvps here
and i remember being in new york and
saying i need to get out of here in
march i went out to a farm in
pennsylvania and realized i have no
skills at all
i i can't do this i can't figure this
out and i was stuck
saying you know this is either going to
make me or break me i decided to move up
to new hampshire
went up there i was supposed to do a
whole tour all around the united states
but ended up staying there
on this synchronistic kind of event i
was looking for an rv
found a friend who needed one fixed it
was you know too expensive for me to
afford i ended up fixing it
at my friend jay nunes big compound
where he literally
is a diesel mechanic and fixer-upper guy
who wears overalls is covered in grease
all the time and could fix
anything with all the tools that he had
in his shed and i i spent
five months there learning just the
basics of being a mechanic just the
basics of welding and also a lot of
survival self-defense training
courses that i ended up teaching people
so it's been
something that's been absolutely
incredible living in the middle of
nowhere and there is
something to say about individuals when
they live in the country
automatically turning more either
libertarian anarchist or
right-wing because of the
self-sufficiency because of the
importance of understanding
that in nature it is wild it is crazy it
is hectic
but it's only you and yourself that are
responsible for your butt
and knowing you know what you know what
makes people right wing when they do
this when they go through this stuff
the hard work the hard work and then
when someone comes along imagine this
you've you worked for eight hours you
finally you know built your little
shelter you got a fire going
you caught some rabbits and then some
dude walk someone goes go get some of
that
you're gonna be like bro i got barely
enough for me and it was really hard to
come on dude share yeah you got more
than me we made people work we had
chickens running around
all over the property people had to
catch them with their bare hands
during my training courses it was pretty
funny to watch because a bunch of city
slickers came
a bunch of people from boston new york
new jersey i came to new hampshire for
my survival training course
and they were literally running around
trying to catch these chickens they had
to catch them
and then they had to chop off their
heads pluck them take out the organs
let's cook them
eat them as they make their own shelter
and it's a lot of work what's the best
trick to catch a fleeing chicken
uh corner it you uh you make a lasso
with uh some twins and then you're
pulling you and you're like yeah and
sometimes even just
walking straight up and and feeding it
or or uh
bird shot oh yeah well no then you're
gonna have a whole bunch of pellets
in your chicken that you're gonna try to
eat and you don't want you don't want
you know
you gotta you gotta do some work you
know but uh but it is easier yeah but
you know making your own shelter making
your own fire filtering your own water
that is an extensive exhausting activity
and those are the basic necessities that
people take advantage of every single
day after going through that chicken
after having to catch it after gutting
it after cutting it after
putting it on the plate and cooking it
you realize how absolutely absurd
it is that there's chicken thighs for a
dollar at walmart you're like what are
they doing
that they have to mass produce such food
so quickly so efficiently to make this
one dollar when it took me all day to
make this chicken to produce it into a
sustainable meal
that's what he called it and it's
literally where
kids come i was a part of the kids i'm
not afraid to admit that and he teaches
them just
basic things like welding using a wrench
using a hammer
making uh shoe horses making hangers
whatever folding steel for his katana
oh that sounds awesome
we did a lot of different stuff but
there is something to say about this
kind of attitude and the type of people
in new hampshire
that are in the wild there's some city
folks there's a big free state project
initiative but one thing that really
sparked
my interest in new hampshire wasn't just
the community but also
the lack of government new hampshire you
don't need car insurance
you don't need helmets you don't need
seat belts when you drive
but they have some of the safest roads
in the united states
they're the number one in homeschooling
with the highest
iq in all of the united states they have
the most bitcoin transactions per capita
go ahead
wow there's a video game youtuber yep
who was playing a game it was called
like city states
and he normally like it's like you
choose how much taxes you want
like you know wages stuff like that and
then you build buildings he decided
as a gag to make a totally lawless
society
under the assumption it would be chaos
and destruction and
fighting and poverty his video is
amazing because his shock and confusion
as he removed all the laws there were no
poor people everybody lived in luxury
buildings there was an abundance of
wealth and he's laughing like what's
happening there's no regulations no
taxes no pollution no
there's no poverty no crime and and
it was gone the video went crazy where
technology's so good that we can go back
to before the era of regulations and
have a new freedom
well there's a lot of yeah if we create
like an ai that just
forces us to live under the courage
encourages us i don't know i'm not for
that but uh but we got crypto we have
like
you know desalination homeschooling and
people
arming themselves and defending
themselves in new hampshire in record
numbers and new hampshire
is one of the most second amendment
friendly states in all of the united
states and it has the least amount of
homicides and gun deaths
in the nation so when you listen though
when you look at it's expensive when it
comes to
let's let's talk about some of the
negatives because you need to talk about
both of the sides here
you do have property taxes but you do
have record low taxes when it comes
everywhere else but the property taxes
are really high
and you do have an opioid epidemic that
has hit new hampshire
extensively hard and you're seeing the
effects of it especially in manchester
where you're seeing a lot of people
addicted to meth so there are positive
positive and negatives it does get
really cold there hence why
i'm here with you living in your parking
lot right now
that's right making my way slowly down
to florida
but i will be back in new hampshire i
absolutely love it there i love the
community and i love individuals we're
gonna get a farm now yeah
so i like that idea too because we might
do i don't know if you want to survival
we might do survival trainings but but
it's not even that's about having fun
grow corn it's about making a video of
luke chasing a chicken around yeah
it's amazing once you get into this hard
work
it's so fun it's so rewarding and it's
so
amazing to be able to do this stuff even
though it is difficult but
that's what life is you know life if
everything was easy if everything was
handed to you if democrats and
the globalist had their way and they
would give you everything
you you wouldn't appreciate it and it
would be filled with think about you
walking to walmart and you're like
i'll just take two fried chickens yes
whole
chickens no dude every time i walk into
walmart i'm like
how much of this are we wasting i hate
it so much i hate that feeling
and what you were talking about raising
kids to like take care of chickens and
stuff like your little camp your little
kids camp
that's how i was raised i remember i
raised chickens to lay eggs that was my
first job now this is my question
towards tim you raise a country like
that that's armed
that prepares their own food that is
ready for fascism that doesn't need
any government that doesn't need
anything how will the chinese invade
like like what was the thing that oh
a bunch of individuals who are
responsible only to themselves and
surviving for themselves
one day a businessman comes along and
says uh we want to
get a proposition for you and we'll pay
you a really great rate to do x y or z
and they'll say yes
and then they start getting this money
and they don't want to back down and
they say now do this now do this now do
this
and slowly but surely they increment
people towards policies that benefit
them
and then you end up with a chinese
businessman comes and buys massive
swathes of property across the western
united states and people just say
yeah amazing maybe what's literally
happening right now
yeah that's exactly what's happening
right now but you have a whole bunch of
lemmings whole bunch of unprepared
people
with their flip-flops and their lattes
being that's not on the government
teeth that aren't even questioning it or
doing anything to
let me ask you a question and are being
independent shout out to
if a china if a chinese businessman came
to you and offered you half a million
dollars for your rv would you say yes
for my uh yeah sure of course you would
and then you'd be like wow now they own
your rv that's what they're doing with
land
and people are going wow and insurance
policies have you seen those commercials
where they want to buy your life
insurance policy
if you don't need your life insurance
policy i haven't seen that it's
insidious people are i don't know about
desperate for money right it's on keeps
showing on the box that's crazy but what
future do you think is possible if
people
became self-sustainable do you think my
future or tim should we do like a voting
thing
i think without without a cohesive
community yeah you'll end up with
but i think we have an identity um
as people and i think that an identity
and i think a culture should come first
and should be prioritized because right
now
culture is being thrown into the trash
it has the worst elements in it right
now that are highlighted it's dominant
promote the most
degenerate uh disgusting behavior
possible that breaks up the family unit
if you look at what they're pushing out
there in mainstream culture it's
drugs it's alcohol it's chemicals it's
it's
you now even have mainline wrappers
talking about the latest
pharma stop that they want to introduce
with themselves wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
cough syrup hold on that's literally
what you've been aspired to be you made
not yet how old you i don't know how the
hell did i look like genetically again
34. 34 years old you gotta get any kids
um working on it 34 no
maybe we'll see no kids driving around
in an rv
you mr mr dmt psychedelics ayahuasca the
thing is there's
what is this judgment here you're gonna
criticize you're gonna criticize
i'm not criticizing no no no no no no no
no no no no no no you're gonna make a
comment on culture
yes and you contribute to that culture
depends maybe
but not to the extensive elements of
totally selling out we all sell out in
some ways
that's basically undeniable because you
there's no other way in mainline
society right now of course but
again we all strive towards being
something better
and i think striving is the first step
into getting it
and i am making decisions and goals that
are a lot different
than they were when they were influenced
by culture because growing up in new
york city growing up in brooklyn
i was absolutely influenced by the worst
elements
of mainstream society and their ideas of
glorifying drug dealers and glorifying
violence and glorifying this idiocy i
was an absolute total victim of it and i
perpetrated it to the
fullest extent well whatever you know
what i mean i'm just you know speaking
expressively here
but essentially when it comes to
understanding it that is the first step
towards defeating it and we could all
be better and i'm making decisions to be
as best as i can and i'm making the best
decision to move away from that and move
forward
and towards the family and kids and
and uh now it's time for something hey
before we go can i uh into super chats
before we continue i want to start
making ammo
i want to just shout out not it's hard
you can yeah you can buy all the pieces
and so i'm looking at getting a bullet
press
um a powder sifter and then i think you
got to buy
a reloader yeah but you're basically
talking about you're talking about
reloading not manufacturing
manufacturing is another level so if you
have any tips uh about how to
manufacture and reload ammo send it to
me on twitter because there's a reason
there's a bullet
shortage because there's a lot of
shortage of the materials that here's
what you need
you need charcoal so burn wood you need
to find sulfur
sulfur mine and you need uh salt peter
so
bat bat crack like potassium potassium
nitrate
you're gonna read the craziest comments
about me here we go super chats if you
haven't already smash the like
button subscribe hit the notification
bell and no no don't worry they're all
gonna be mad about me
we'll see kevin kane mentions uh the new
proposal a round of stimulus 15
but only for those who take the vaccine
not a joke tim i sent you a link on
instagram
that is a crazy story i did pull that up
rose says let's talk about a
preponderance of evidence instead of
widespread
well you don't need widespread evidence
to change the results of an election if
you just can get
a swing county to have a swing which
gives a state which gives a country to a
certain president
morning featherhart says the gulags of
tomorrow will not be physical camps but
digital excision from society
bans from social networks and financial
institutions maybe even isps
and you might as well be living in the
wild
bitcoin she made a very good point with
a lot of people already having their
banking
online banking taken away from them
because of their political opinions that
has already happened in the united
states
so i think the corporate overlords are
somewhat of a bigger threat sometimes
than
the actual government when you were
asking how to get out of china's grasp
too i thought getting off the us dollar
and kind of diversifying into crypto is
one way to
protect yourself against chinese
corruption and invasion that just that
just protects you as an individual and
sacrifices the rest
we need to do that response
stop it yeah james high says everyone
here should sign the petition from
we the people convention for trump to
declare martial law and
that is a bold statement uh he says this
was a theft and the american people know
it
i don't know about that i think that
declaration is an invitation for civil
war
and uh i don't think people realize what
war is like it's funny when they're like
i don't want i don't want martial law i
want martial law
yeah exactly it's crazy left is like we
should have
martial law the most extreme lockdowns
ever how dare trump call for the same
thing
yeah it's insane the civic nationalist
says luke
speak to tim kennedy he is active sf and
runs a school
tim wednesday war of 1812 james madison
declared the war to invade bna
1776 was over taxes for the seven years
war
nice to see the gondo working
it'll be cool to have a gong here mafu
says this guy is already more likable
than destiny can you ask luke to say i
don't know as a test
i don't know because i don't know
let's see uh someone mentioned trump
bringing troops home uh uh sending 800
troops back from somalia
i read that he was going to move him
around to different bases so well it's
supposed to happen in 2021
which is which which if biden comes in
he's probably going to reverse that
you mentioned us having troops in
pakistan what was that there's a lot of
training forces
inside of pakistan right now that are
training different uh sects
of militants in that specific region if
you know pakistan it's
essentially still a wild west with many
factions vying for power
and the united states is invested in
certain powers they're prevailing so
they are training
a whole bunch of pakistani uh
paramilitaries for their own kind of
benefit
tom me says are these judges and media
making judgments on the criminal
standard
beyond a reasonable doubt or the civil
standard of 51
of probability this uh what we're seeing
in all of the fraud cases is
arbitrary semantic debate the media will
desperately say there's no evidence they
misconstrue what bill barr says
and they just they're clearly
lying and trying ken abbott says stop
calling them mainstream media
it implies credibility call them legacy
media it implies yesterday's culture and
technology yeah good point
justin dube says if you take your
corruption case to the corrupt what do
you expect to happen
that's how i feel about all this
election fraud stuff right now like who
do we expect
to tell us that it was fraud that's true
matthew felton says if trump wins we
have a few more riots national guard
called and done
if biden wins then in my opinion 60
chance of the move starting around
february
um i'm thinking slightly after march
uh depends when he's going to try to
confiscate firearms
or impose the tax on firearms then i
think
really is going to be a big touch i
don't i think that's irrelevant i think
that's
a good point i think the the national
lockdown will result i don't think what
we're going to see is like a bunch of
trump supporters
like conservatives putting on armor and
then marching and lift
left what's going to happen is there's
going to be areas like in new hampshire
where a bunch of people you know
probably say
it's not going to happen here and
they're going to put it roadblocks and
they're going to stand guard and say
don't come in here we don't care what
you have to say
we have a constitution in this country
we'll see another that's when it ignites
three trillion bailout then
probably another one then we'll see
breadlines and then they're going to see
violence in the brexit
bro we already have that that already
happened this year we haven't seen
violence
in the red lines yes we did we
earlier in the year numerous times in
the red lines people started fighting
each other and breaking trying to
break into the there was one instance
where they broke down the fence broke
into the building and started just
taking boxes of food and running off
with it and that's that's
and then the people there started
throwing the food because people were
going nuts demanding it
so yes food and that was artificial they
made that happen by
taking people's ability to work away we
got we have fat homeless people in this
country it's crazy yeah there's
that's not the the issue was that they
said none none for you
jared backman says ian you hurt my head
but that's why i love you keep speaking
your honest thoughts brother
thank you jared i love you too man
badger toe says destiny has has no idea
election night he
he uh was telling us red coats we didn't
lock down after we locked down from
march to july
trump orders somalia troop withdrawal
crazy
let's see kermit thrush says biden at
270 means one faithless electors throws
it to trump
hilldog had four validated faithless
electors the supreme court ruled they
can't do that though
i guess i suppose regardless of that
they could say no
and just cause some kind of
constitutional crisis yeah
let's see stacy uh stacey murphy says
trump train is gaining momentum
forensic audits audits footage of the
votes being counted unlawfully
real data of unlawful voters having
voted keep those windows boarded up
that's all true that's all true uh uh
georgia has ordered a signature
verification finally
following the release of this video
footage showing people counting with no
observers and then claiming there were
observers doesn't matter it's in dispute
and there is real data from matt brainer
the voter integrity project
there was on on fox news today they had
on a guy who said
the judge in nevada has received a list
of 30
i think he said 35 000 names of people
who either voted twice in two different
states
or voted in nevada without having legal
residency
the judge has it we'll see how he rules
35
000 and the margin in nevada 10k
that's crazy oh yeah
sergeant hotel says guys the people's
pundit examined ga video and found
election worker loading the same bouts
three times into counting tabulator this
cannot be debunked by mainstream media
interesting so not just the video of
them pulling them out but the peop the
people then scanning and then scanning
and then scanning again
interesting chris pavetto says
lately when we chat about reform on
policy uh policies police and government
it seems to teeter near accepting a few
ideas from the great reset
where do we find the balance of
liberties plus reform without people
having opening uh
opening arms agreeing to reset that's a
big challenge
um because it is true that you know when
people say like oh we should social
distance and we should we should
you know wear masks and do certain
things it's people saying we accept some
of what they're what they're putting
forward and maybe it's because people
are acting in good faith
that we don't we know there's there's
coveted we know it's got lingering
effects that are very damaging we know
it can kill old people we don't want it
we want people to die
so we want to be rational reasonable
individuals but they're not being
reasonable in return who
the government the democratic governors
then sangri says can ian read the quote
out loud i think he will get it if he
reads it which quote was that
i don't know buy it in quote oh that's
right that's right yeah oh i see what
you're saying thank you
i'll do that later actually i'm probably
gonna listen to it again and again
right let's see go to sleep to it
jessica i'm not brolson says trump
answers only to
to his ideals for america i think he
didn't pardon assange because his source
is a national security issue
but my favorite trump thing is he
answers to no one except the people
and his vision of america at its best
well i think
most people want pot legalized
and they want non-violent uh offenders
with review
to be pardoned nonviolent drug offenses
um the review is because some might
plead down to lesser charges and they
maybe are violent
and i think the people want snowden and
assange pardoned i think that's
overwhelmingly trump supporters agree
with this i look at some of the trump
forums where they're saying assange and
snowden expose the deep state trump
should pardon them outright
there's a reason every presidential
candidate campaigns on ending the war
and giving people more civil liberties
so i think that's very clear and i think
that's what government should do if they
keep promising it
all right let's see what we got omega
b3n says the needs of the individual are
the needs of the many
because the many are made of individuals
this is why individual rights benefit
everyone
i agree we are only as strong as our
weakest link that's very true
every person that person that's a very
good comment and very good commentary
especially
how politicians and elected officials
should be seeing
uh you know each citizen the biggest
minority of them all
is the individual and we should protect
that individual at all costs
acoustic theory says journal nature
medicine quote a sars-like cluster of
circulating bat chronoviruses shows
potential for human emergence co-author
xi li wuhan institute of virology 2015
gain of function study that's what luke
was bringing up
thanks for that alex jones mentioned
there was an article from new scientists
that said they were developing
something they called sarskovit ii and
you know and they were like this is not
the same thing it wasn't new
it was like new dash scientist is it
different than the new scientists it was
a news
newsguard certified source that's all
and then jones was like well microsoft
says it's good then it must be good
right i'm like there you go because they
they fund it
glitchy boy says in regards to trusting
service members i'd trust an enlisted
member maybe a lieutenant
but no one captain or higher higher
ranking officers are basically military
politicians
i hear that essentially yeah binary
evasion says
if you watch the video on the after
hours vote counting you will see the
lady in purple scan the same ballot
stack
three times whoa
i mean how do you deny that he can't is
it getting spicy he was
the dash scientist scientist thanks
rita ho says i am from taiwan and i am
scared what would happen to my family
friends and people in taiwan in the next
four years if biden eventually becomes
the potus
because china is preparing for the
invasion and the annexation of taiwan
we talked about this wednesday
extensively and joe biden's gonna go
he's gonna be sitting there with his
furled brow as there's gonna be video
playing of destroyers like and then
u-boats storming the beaches and he's
gonna go
come on come on man
absolutely correct the fact of the
matter he loves that phrase
he loves his lists one something
something two here's something
something eric miller says luke
rudkowski is actually an alias
he's actually kick buttowski suburban
daredevil all grown up i knew it kidding
love the show and keep up the good work
oh
is that a real person citizen seven says
i'll bet ten dollars this super chat
never gets read oh
now you have to super chat more
david franco jr says this dude is a
smart dude he knows what's up and can
defend his position with quickness well
actually luke's written it all down
because he's probably
i like taking notes and i like studying
and i like you know
knowing my stuff but i'm not always
right i get things wrong no one's
perfect and
i'm infallible just like everybody else
i've been watching but do your own
homework
this is my main thing i've been saying
from my first video don't ever trust me
do your own homework do your own
research and i want to make sure i'm
prepared so you guys know what to
research and study yourself
so you can make up your own mind i've
been watching luke since 2010
2009 and his his work is incredible like
looking back i believe that humanity
will
will look at it as a boon
i don't know i was just fascinated with
your stuff no no no no no no no
it was so history
some of the stuff that you guys were
doing kept us out of the syrian war
right almost it was it was a roadblock
yeah dude check out we are changed a lot
of the stuff that was going on
in the early 2010s from independent
media many of the hacker
journalist types and data data
researchers really did
work really well to stop the conflict in
many places there was no restrictions on
independent media back then it was just
beginning to restrict independent voices
third party voices smaller voices mom
and pop shop
media organization voices that actually
made the difference and told people the
truth
and that's why it was such a threat and
that's why they're shutting it down
and they've shut us down very
effectively and they limited
they limited my organization extremely
hard and they hit me very hard
i'm barely you know surviving but i am
in the wilderness
yeah mikitaly says i'd love to go to man
camp sounds amazing is it only in new
hampshire or is there a man camp in
camifornia
uh no man camp is in new hampshire under
j
noon but if you go to the free state
project you could probably get involved
with that we have a large number of
projects and different things we're
doing i'm going to be back there for the
spring
and i'm going to be doing more survival
training courses there if i can't find
more ones
down the road from here all the way to
florida
heather cummins says you can't store
enough food you need a renewable food
source
i raise meat rabbits i butcher 30 a
month to feed the family chickens too
but do you guys know rabbit starvation
is no rabbits don't have enough fat
so it's something called rabbit
starvation where people only eat rabbits
but you eventually aren't getting enough
you know nutrients and fat your body
needs to to survive
so rabbits you can eat and uh you can
you can raise them
probably got supplemented with chickens
you know maybe some kind of plant
coconut i tell you that's why people are
gonna a lot of people will probably move
to a climate where you can get
year-round
farming mm-hmm or you go to you go to a
place like florida there's just
fruit and foods everywhere just like
swampland yep
daniel hawk says lids and ian are bae
tim is okay but i love him anyway
luke rocks yeah jared thiel says
question for luke
dude you look exactly like me i assume
you're polish are you prussian
plus i've also talked about guns as
assets to people thank you
uh polish born and raised prove it speak
polish
what we are going to do
maybe we'll see but no i i'm
very polish very proud um you know
we had we just had pierogies at the
house couple days ago we did it was good
and it was
pretty good sour cream yeah potato and
sausage of some sort pierogies pickles
sauerkraut all the way
let's see what is this what is this we
got uh we just said it youtube
i love it when they jump we get too many
super chats at once and then success
problem
lance atwell says harrison deal a
loffler staffer
and governor kemp's daughter's boyfriend
died this morning in a car crash that
looked like he hit a pallet of c4
people are talking about that's crazy
stuff yeah we were looking at that
earlier right
you know the thing is people think it's
political yeah and this is what i say
when you see stuff like this they
you know people will be like you're
gonna hear on the left no no no it's no
big deal
you're gonna people on the right saying
this is fishy something's going on
it doesn't matter what's true you know
why it matters what people believe and
people are at such a point
where they really distrust each other
where they're gonna say this is
political
or they're going to make the insinuation
and be like look at this it's crazy
right you're right
sometimes car accidents happen exactly
you know that's true too
but hey sometimes political hits happen
not entirely sure why some like
low-level staffer for a you know senate
candidate
i mean i get it it's one of the most
contentious senate races right now but
you know let's see justin smith says did
i miss the coverage of the latest biden
gaffe
you did yep it was funny i will resign
citizen 7 says i'm paying up i'm a man
of my word good on you citizen seven
marksman says hey tim love the show
could you read the poem by henry lawson
every man should own a rifle the poem is
dated in 1907
so before world war one and the
similarity to now is uncanny keep it the
good work love the music video
you should look at it right now it's uh
the poem by henry lawson every man
should own a rifle
rachel taylor says we assume that dirty
work is all behind closed doors
so the left can showcase corruption as
long as we are fearing what we can't see
indeed media shines a light on the creep
in the corner sniffing hair
keep shining for us we'll try my best
bass player says hey tim check out
serpenza and la
86 for guests both lived in china for
years and currently live in california
yes they are on my short list
hey luke tim ian and liz what do you
think about hr 5736
2011 2012 that has made section 230
erode from its original intent and made
twitter the hell whole it has become
with the propaganda yes i don't know
what those house resolutions
are or that house resolution is me
neither jake durham
uh durham says it'd be pretty pretty
cool if you had on trumper for yang
he can make a solid conservative case
for ubi and maybe show some nuance to it
let's shift the culture i'd that'd be
that'd be pretty interesting i'd love to
do that
calvin says luke if i can't trust the
start of your claims then you might as
well have the seven-figure como salary
on cnn
well let's see tyler for page says tim
only knows how to make gunpowder because
of dr stone
uh no it's because luke was like you
should make bullets and i was like let's
google search how to do it and it was
like sulfur charcoal and saltpeter
and then i was like where did we get
those things and it was like sulfur
mines burning wood
and bat poop uh what was the other place
to get
a nighter from from what fertilizer yes
what you have to make that i mean if you
i mean you have to
like we're talking about in the wild if
you're in the middle of the woods
naked i'm not playing with no bat bat
poop in 2020
you're in the middle of the woods you're
buck naked how do you make bullets how
do you make gunpowder uh
first you get a spear um and you use
that then you get a bow
and yeah go from there yeah but um
and you know i i don't know i don't i
haven't gone that far yet then you look
for red rocks
and you melt them in your fire and then
you fold the steel 50 times
then you stab a a deer
someone's uh it's crazy canuck says love
the show keep it the good work guys
keep it real look forward to what y'all
come up with next cheers from canada
nick smith says guess i'll be enlisting
in the taiwanese military
ben boucher says great show guys i'd say
top 10 tim cast it's always fun watching
two old friends and titans of indy news
go at it
keep it the great work we need both of
you right now and that's why luke is in
a trailer in my parking lot
luke's living in a parking lot yeah yeah
but but now that
now that i've made the joke luke's got
one of the most epic rv production
setups
i'm so jealous it's like a 2013 old
trailer but it's i went out to very cool
i went on bought one
yes just today tim just bought one today
we just came from
the moment it's not hard it's financing
it's a couple hundred bucks a month
which if the dollar collapses you know
and also people need to know
it was a little contentious today that's
how me and tim have been talking to each
other ever since
like day one we've been what i said
we've been debating and arguing like
this for a while and i absolutely love
it we don't see eye to eye on many
things and i love the debates i love
iron sharpening iron
i love the challenges and i think it's
awesome that we could be friends for so
long
and disagree so much and be able to
still
at the end of the day do really cool
stuff and back and let me live in your
parking lot
back in 2011 i was like luke one day
i'm going to be like in my late 50s and
i'm going to be the ceo of this massive
media conglomerate and and you know i'm
going to have like this suit on
walking out of a big meeting with the
president and then you're going to run
up to me and be like
tim how why did you i'm going to try to
take you down by confronting outside of
you making it
look out of here you get them on your
security and you're going to be like
what happened to you man you've changed
and i'm like get out of here
and then i'm going to like brush off my
my expensive ten thousand dollar suit
and then be like drive then and then
throw 100 bills at the window
literally when he was down the block in
a car and i followed his car for about
20 blocks running after it in the middle
of new york city
got him at it remember when we randomly
bumped into rumsfeld that was amazing
yes and asked them about what was it the
seven trillion dollars that was missing
what are you talking about i took a
selfie from i took a selfie with him
and then you know it was just absolutely
and he was like there was missing money
yeah no idea
what about that we ran into anderson
cooper which uh was also a very
you asked him if he was in the city you
didn't like yeah you asked him if he was
in the cia no i asked him about
operation mockingbird and how cia
officials were caught manipulating the
mainstream media why are you asking
anderson because he was trained as a
city agent yeah
exactly yes he spent two years with the
cia
whoa before before he print he left
printed his own press badge and flew
himself to
uh i think was it rock to cover i don't
know exactly but he's the son of a
vanderbilt he holds a lot of
power and influence in higher society
and new year's eve
silver fox and he deserves some
questioning and i'd just like to
you know let i would love to know his
his point of view about the cia in the
mainstream media and their long history
together as they've been you know
working together
awesome that's what i did tim didn't
like that though he got mad at me
because it's it felt like you just it's
i know i know i know
but there's specific things you could
have asked them about yes there's
there's photos out of cnn there was
the accusations that cnn was staging so
i confronted him three times
uh and one of them was about their kind
of obsession about
iraq and syria and how horrible they are
but not saudi arabia
exactly so you know that's another thing
so yeah so when i was with you and you
were like the cia i was like you could
have asked him something specific
well i did i had many i know i know and
then he ran away with his all of
security guards and hidden what did he
say to you he was like come on
dude when you asked him about that he
was really sassy he got mad he got a lot
of sass i heard he doesn't wash his
pants
now we're talking i don't know he was
brought up on his
on his show around the same time that's
why i bring it up it was someone
talking to him and he started laughing
and they were like is it true of the
rumors you don't wash your jeans
like when you're working he's wearing
jeans and he never washes them and he
laughed and he was like i don't and then
they were like they started laughing at
him
yeah that's funny though he's a hippie
robert stratton says tim before you give
mr soda a free pass due to non-violence
please weigh that against the vulnerable
people
people's lives you may have put at risk
just saying uh
the thing about snowden he's not a
whistleblower he's a leaker there's a
big difference
julian assange is literally just a
journalist
uh unless they can come up with some
other evidence accusing him of anything
the same thing with snowden
snowden's issue is i've actually been
pretty critical of snowden
however i still think that
given the circumstances of what we
uncovered and the fact that it's now
been quite a long
time and the the the tremendous good
that came out of it
i kind of roll my eyes and say i think i
think he should be pardoned it's for me
it is rather a
bit of a coin toss but considering you
know uh what we learned about the nsa
the spying the
the the deep state lies under oath kind
of stuff at that point i'm like
just just just generally hated women
swore under oath
exactly no spying progress exactly no
one was being followed no one was being
tracked no one was being databased i
went up to him
and i confronted him about the nsa
officers that were caught
uh spanking it to people's private uh
pictures which was which actually
happened but no one believed it
until edward snowden explains the
information uh and so that's very hayden
even when i confronted him one-on-one
about that he was like it never happened
i don't know what you're talking about
you're crazy
i'm like you're spying on people he's
like nope assange shouldn't be locked up
for any reason at all yeah it's clearly
they're trying to if you're gonna lock
up assange you're gonna have to lock up
you know people from any news
organization from anywhere around the
world if they say anything negative
about the united states that's the very
dangerous president
that julian assange sets he's a
publisher he released information
and he's not even an american citizen
and you add all those layers together
if he goes to jail that sets a very very
dangerous president for
anyone who wants to say anything about
the us government in the future
jerry lee says tim the gunpowder you
mentioned is black powder it's different
be careful
we'll do it yes yeah let's not play
around with that until we get some
professional
i thought i thought that was important
to mention because i don't want anyone
to think we're not doing it
right right right but we're building
into it i also read that
people can make black powder but you can
use ammonium nitrate instead of
potassium
but that's really really dangerous
because it's concussive clearly we need
more research and
uh well just don't professionals yeah so
we're not doing it i bring that bit up
to say
do not do that however i would like to
foray into learning how
i think under controlled circumstances
with professional who can teach you how
to do it
that's what you guys got to do that
being said it is 10 30. luke thanks for
hanging out what do you what's
what's your plan you're going to get in
you're going to go in the parking lot
take your rv and
head off back into wild blue yonder um
i'm going to be making my way
south unless tim could keep me here he's
trying to keep me here maybe i don't
know it's a battle royale
there's a there could be we can't we're
trying the details we're trying to
break the internet yes and if if we're
gonna break the internet i will
definitely be here
we're talking about plans that we can't
tell you right now i'm i hate to do this
the biggest
podcast in existence that will ever
happen
yeah it's gonna be wild so if that
happens i'm here
maybe i'll stay with him i don't know i
like i'm like a hippie in many kind of
different aspects of my life i might go
down south i'm still looking for places
to do survival training so i could
offset my youtube losses since i've been
demonetized
my main youtube channel is we are change
check me out there your support is
extremely appreciated and means more
than ever to me
and thank you for having me and thanks
for debating with me and thanks for
being a friend for so long and
thanks for letting me crash in your
parking lot i'll send you the invoice
for the parking lot
you can follow me on twitter instagram
parlor at tim cast check out my other
channels
youtube.comtimcastnyoutube.comcastnews
we are live monday through friday 8pm
check us out on itunes and spotify
give us some love leave us a good review
and check out tomorrow we put up clips
from the show so if you didn't see the
whole show
there will be segments coming up about
all the debates and all the fun stuff we
do and we'll break things down
and we'll be we will be back what's
what's today today's friday today's
friday
it's friday we'll be back monday 8 p.m
and we're gonna have uh a really fun
week next week so we got some
progressive
progressives or a progressive coming we
do so this should be an interesting
conversation for sure
don't forget to follow ian yesterday in
crossland all over the internet uh
before i go i'd like to ask you luke you
have um
merchandise you were showing me a little
bit of it where can people check out
your merch
thank you so much for generously doing
that if you wish to have the hat
or the shirt that i had on in the last
video it is on teesprings.com forward
slash stores forward slash we are change
or just we are change.org you could
probably get it there but thank you i
appreciate it
and don't forget to follow at sour patch
lids that's correct i am in fact on
twitter for my sins
sour patch lids lyds subscribe
hit the notification bell hit that like
button check us out on all podcast
platforms leave us a good review we will
be
uh eternally grateful and share let
people know if you like the show and you
know to come and check it out
we uh we do our best thanks so much for
hanging out and we will see you all
monday at 8pm
bye guys
you